foreign
[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is thirteen o'clock
ah here we are it's saturday yeah we're
here
again where else would we be
man we didn't we need to [ __ ] i want
to start going out on saturdays we need
to [ __ ] change the show
friday some next month at least well it
it almost is next month because
i think to isn't tomorrow the last day
of february because february is a short
month
it only has 28 days so we might be
getting into march all right
i don't know it's we might decide to
move it to friday
this coming week yeah but we'll see how
it goes sorry somebody just came
in yeah so did uh soph
says zim michael shaffer's in
deborah's in everybody's hearing
everybody's showing up yeah
yeah all right everybody's here for
saturday yeah
sabrina's in bee's nest
dj maniac okay
yeah all right everybody's here yep
today's gonna be a pretty good show it's
gonna be a true crime show yeah we
haven't
done one of those in a way i will say
yeah texas killing texas
i will say that what ended up happening
with um
the the patreon poll the votes
uh there was actually a tie between
texas killing fields and phoenix lights
but because we hadn't done a true crime
show in so long i was kind of like well
i'll flip a coin
and see but i really would kind of
rather do texas killing fields because
ginny doesn't like ufos though well yeah
and plus like and plus like the past few
weeks we hadn't really done a lot of
true crime we'd done like a lot of cults
and like other kind of stuff so i was
like i really want to get back into
doing true
crime the weird thing i've had a lot of
people request us do texas killing
fields and i
thought for a long time that we had done
it already but i think the reason that i
thought that was because i had written
about it
in uh my book and faceless villain
so so i was real familiar with the case
and that's why every time i read about
it i kept thinking it's like we must
have done this before but i guess i did
a search and we didn't
phoenix slice is gonna be good though
that's still gonna be a good case
there's something that went on there
yeah the governor and [ __ ] [ __ ]
confirmed that he saw it
a lot of people saw that you know the
9-1-1 call centers picked up
a lot of [ __ ] and there's stuff that the
air force did that [ __ ] real suspect
you know looks like a psyop on top of it
try to make people not believe that
something happened
i think something happened there just
they didn't have an explanation for it
they didn't want to talk about it yeah
one of these days we'll get around to
doing that
yeah it's just like i said there's a lot
in that case
and a lot of it's misinformation like
the flares thing
yeah and there's a video of [ __ ]
flares that look you know that that's
probably flares
but why were flares being dropped so
close to that city
and it was after the after the the
reports came in there's a lot of little
details
it looks like they went up and dropped
some flares after the report
so they could say oh no you just saw
flares so i could
confuse these they like went up there
real quick yeah put some [ __ ] that could
maybe
be ufos yeah and it came back down and
says no no you saw some flares
but the time in which they photographed
those flares that was like several hours
after the the initial reports of it in
that location
and there's some [ __ ] thank you dermot
yeah thanks
london there's some [ __ ] in that
there's some [ __ ] in those videos that
does not jive
it doesn't add up some of it does not
add up to flares
i've seen you can't see the smoke coming
off the top of the flares and that's
just
every time i've ever seen any any
military flares you can see the
parachute and you can see the smoke
now video quality may not have been good
but
still and and those things the distance
in between those flares is [ __ ]
constant through the whole thing
and it's never like that in reality the
wind blows them around around a
random places i mean we can get to that
on that show but
no yeah we'll get to that something
happened
something happened there was a big old
[ __ ] aircraft some kind of
large craft flew over that people
thought was extraterrestrial tila says
she's drinking
vodka and grapefruit i'm drinking vodka
with pineapple and
mango and guava
all in the same with with a with a
little bit of lemon juice in it fruity
yeah it's like a magic punch
i have a cream sickle yeah i made her
cream whipped cream vodka and orange
juice yeah
and ice running low on orange juice so i
don't have enough for her
to have orange juice so i'm drinking
punch
i don't even know you had bunch in there
no i made my own punch oh okay
that's right because you get all those
others yeah i got all those little
juices yeah
these nuts says i can't drink alcohol i
got ulcers yeah
that sucks but you know
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do tila says that's a hawaiian cocktail
tom i know
you're saying you should you should put
like some [ __ ] umbrellas and [ __ ] in
there yeah make that [ __ ] fruity as [ __ ]
i'll put a damn slice of pineapple on
there yeah put a good umbrella
let everybody know that i'm in [ __ ]
florida put a little rubber shark on
there
[Laughter]
i uh
i want to say that it was red lobster
maybe i could be remembering it wrong
but i feel like
they had they used to have this cocktail
it was like really this is probably back
in the 90s
they had this really big tall cocktail
and it was blue and i'm pretty sure it
had
a rubber or plastic shark on it like for
a garnish
all those blue ones are good they're
kind of like a coconut
flavor like a pina colada flavor yeah
that's what you get a damn chinese rest
of the flaming fudge yeah i'm into that
[ __ ] blue
[Laughter]
the blue hawaii you know it's a [ __ ]
big old [ __ ] bowl and in the middle
of it there's a glass floating and it's
on fire
there's a bunch of straws
[Laughter]
[ __ ] plastic swords with [ __ ]
little fruit on them
[Laughter]
just like a drink with all this
ridiculous [ __ ] yeah ridiculous [ __ ]
oh my god but uh yeah so
do okay so i don't know if we have any
shout outs particularly because i don't
think we don't have any new patrons or
anything like that
um one thing i don't wanna shout out
look at this because when we did the
dark disney show and remember i told you
i got
super obsessed with the history of the
haunted mansion both in disney world and
disneyland
so i ordered this book in edges game
today so i'm very very excited like to
get to read this unauthorized sister of
walt disney's haunted mansion
by the guy that runs the doom buggies
doom buggies yeah so he's kind of a
haunted mansion
connoisseur what's up louie
[Laughter]
um that's how you get your five fruits
and veggies that's right that's
it's healthy this is that's what i
figure i figured this is this is my
fruit for this my vitamin c for the day
i mean t let's see and i should have
worn one of those hawaiian lays around
my right
yeah i used to have one but i think it
looked hokey as [ __ ]
oh come on look cool that shirts on
that's the other [ __ ] straw hat you
can do like jimmy buffett
yeah what's funny is that they'll put
that [ __ ] on but [ __ ] hawaii's
far from [ __ ] here man it is that's
far away
it's very far away wrong ocean
[Laughter]
wrong ocean wrong ocean uh but yeah so
as i mentioned earlier um i've kind of
wanted to get back into doing the true
crime because we hadn't done it in a
while like i said this is a case that i
that has been requested multiple times
and i thought we'd already done it but
we didn't
uh just i talked about it for my book so
i thought we had already done it
now in preparation for this it would tom
watch the 48 hours about it um
i also watched the 48 hours about it i
also watched
uh dark minds that one with that like
really over dramatic dude that had that
talks to raven the serial killer
that one i watched that um i also
watched the
two and a half hour time suck episode on
this the podcast
um i watched i don't know why but the
fictional
movie that was kind of based very very
loosely based on this case which came
out in 2011
uh it had sam worthington and uh jeffrey
dean morgan he played negan on walking
dead yeah
uh so they were in it it was highly
fictionalized good movie though it was
on tubey it's on pluto tv too for free
if you want to watch it
and uh where most of this information
came from because
one thing about the texas killing fields
that's very frustrating to me
is that the wikipedia page and i know
it's wikipedia but the wikipedia page
um is real uh threadbare um
if you look up texas killing fields
location as opposed to texas killing
fields of the movie
um it really it has this chart of all
the victims of which there are many
and it just has a couple of sentences
about
hey they were last seen at this store
and then their skeleton was found like
six months later or whatever and that's
like all they said
about the victims and that kind of
bummed me out
so um probably the definitive book
on this case um although it's been a
while i think it came out the first
edition i think came out in 2011 and
then there was another volume in 2014 or
second edition
is called uh deliver us three decades of
murder and redemption in the infamous
i-45 texas killing fields by
katherine casey so i actually bought the
e-book
version of that for 3.99 or how much it
was and
i read that because i wanted a lot more
detail about the victims particularly
and you know other [ __ ] about the crime
scene because even on the wikipedia page
they don't even really say like how the
victims were killed
which to me seems a pretty significant
detail to leave out
so uh so yeah i read that and uh it's
really really good i recommend it
i will say though because it came out i
guess the second edition i think in 2014
um two of the victims that were
unidentified
from a long time ago were actually
identified in
2019 so they're still referring to them
in this book as like unidentified
victims but they have been
identified uh subsequently they were
just identified last year
so you know if you keep that in mind
that there have been a few updates in
the case
since the book came out we're gonna talk
about all the known victims too
yeah it's actually really good and some
people that uh
maybe got away from the [ __ ] yeah and
suspects and people who are arrested
yeah because this so okay so
if you don't know i guess we might as
well just go ahead and get right into it
because like i said i don't think we
have any other uh shout outs
particularly
no the um the killing fields
is a place in between um
houston and galveston using houston
galveston
and it's kind of like the bermuda
triangles of body dumps
yeah just there's a lot of bodies that
were dumped there in the past 40 years
and they don't know how many of them are
connected they know they're not all
connected because they've caught several
guys doing it
out here over the years but a lot of
them are still on a lot of them are
still unsolved and a lot of them were
kind of done in
the same kind of time clusters around
the same time and
it's weird i i think there's at least
four or five guys dumping bodies there
although i will say and i don't think
this is a spoiler alert necessarily but
um i think a lot of investigators do
think
that um of the 11
roughly 11 uh murders that took place in
the 70s
like from between 1971 and 1878 i think
it was
um most of the most detectives i believe
think that that those were all committed
by the same person yeah
yeah um you know and we'll get into who
that is
who it probably is later although he
hasn't he was never convicted of it
probably died they couldn't pin it on
him
no okay um but you know the murders
continued into the 80s 90s
there were even some weird [ __ ] that
happened like in the early 2000s that i
don't know if it's
related but you know so this is
several multiple multiple serial killers
that are using this small area i mean
really
when they're talking about the texas
killing fields they generally mean it's
about a 25 acre
area it's uh basically like i said it's
between houston and galveston which if
you're not from the us
is an island on an island off the coast
of texas
so it's along uh interstate 45
which is you know the main highway that
goes between those two cities
and it's weird because you know
houston is a massive city
but you go a little bit outside of
houston
on interstate 45 and there's kind of
like all these
oil oil fields like refineries there's
all these there's all this marsh land
so there's like a lot of empty area
so it seems like sort of the serial
killers
perfect [ __ ] i mean you can be anywhere
around in the area you can
grab somebody sadly kill them
drive a couple of minutes off i-45
dump the body get back on i-45 and you'd
be [ __ ] gone then no one would ever
catch you
and um that seems to be what has been
happening at least since the early 1970s
so this is kind of another thing i think
i mentioned this a while
back when we did the show about london
ontario uh you know serial killer
capital
you know in the 60s and 70s i feel like
this is a case where it's kind of like a
perfect storm of geographical
um factors that make it really really
appealing
to people of let's call it serial killer
proclivities
it's an ideal dumping ground it is if
you look at it
if you look at aerial photographs of it
or you looking to see what it look what
the terrain looks like you know when
you're on the ground
you've got a freeway one freeway going
one way another freeway going another
and they both have access to [ __ ]
basically kind of like
they're not it's not a wooded area but
it it's it's
probably grassland to be a way or mars
yeah it's marshes
you know what you call it it's kind of
by use
all that kind of [ __ ] so no matter which
way you're going you have access to the
to the wooded area or the excuse me
the grass lands on either side of it so
you can get off the road and back on the
road very easily
and there's just and it's just
unpopulated so it's it's going to make a
good dumping ground
you know if you're going to use it in
the middle of the night
you know which i guess i guess it's in
the middle of night when they do the
dumps
you know nobody's ever been seen yeah
which to me is like pretty
middle of the night probably but as i
said if you see
pictures of the area i mean they even
call that stretch of interstate 45 the
highway to hell
yeah not only because of all the serial
killing but also because there's like a
really lot of accidents on that road too
like a lot of fatal accidents for
whatever reason so it's just it's not a
happy area
all around also i think too one factor
that was brought up by a few of the uh
investigators was that because houston
is such a massive city
and you know they have so much uh you
know they have a bunch of oil refineries
they have a bunch of
they have a bunch of heavy industry that
tends to attract
contract workers um you know or people
they're transient they just kind of come
into the town they work for a few months
for
you know on a contract and then they
move somewhere else so anywhere
that you have a large population
of people who don't live there year
round that are just kind of coming and
going
i guess you're going to see this type of
this type of activity as well
like i said i think that was the same
thing that happened with london ontario
in the 60s and 70s
where it was just like this you know
this this large populated area but they
hadn't really
con had any connection until like they
opened up this big highway
and then all of a sudden you know all
this new prey opened up like to look at
it from a serial killer
standpoint so i guess that's what you're
seeing in this
situation so from
the canonical i guess texas killing
fields murder there were some other that
were kind of on the outside that hurt
that maybe are connected maybe not i
mean it's horrifying how many [ __ ]
bodies
uh have turned up how many
disappearances have turned up just in
this
you know relatively small area uh so
starting in the early 1970s until about
the mid to late 90s with you know
a couple more like later on there have
been at least
30 bodies all girls and young women
most between the age of 12 and 25 that
have been found in here there have also
been a bunch of disappearances
um you know whose bodies have not been
found yet but we're presuming that
uh that they are connected as well like
i said there
there's got to be at least
i mean just from the people they've
caught for some of these
other than the people they've caught one
two three four but i mean there's got to
be at least [ __ ] seven or eight of
these [ __ ] running around and a
bunch of them they haven't caught yet
yeah which is horrifying it's horrifying
how many of these like [ __ ] scumbags
are running around
scary we'll talk about it we'll talk
about the ones that they caught
yeah one was from louisiana
he was yet yeah yeah we'll get into that
too
michael shafer says bee's in texas he
can tell you about the chupacabra maybe
the chupacabra is doing it i don't know
that would exp that would be just as
[ __ ]
explicable as the rest of this crazy and
they're amazed that we're already on
topic and that we haven't been
sidetracked
yet and we're already talking about the
case this early in on the show i'm
amazed too well everybody showed up
earlier you know everybody showed up and
you know so we got a decent crowd to my
and we didn't have a lot to talk about
in terms of uh we didn't have shout outs
so
you know we're just going to get on it
and this may be long and we're having
computer problems so
yeah we got to we got to get on this
case and get cracking because we're
going to detail each victim
everything you know about each other
like just a little bit um you know cause
i i at least know what about all the
details i at least wanted like
more [ __ ] about them than was on the
wikipedia page because like i said even
on the wikipedia page they didn't say
how most of them
died um you know which is kind of just a
strangulation in it
uh not always not always they're all all
just
all different different not all of them
were different but some of them are
different
okay uh but yeah i think too the you
know because you
knew about the case because you watched
the documentary that i knew about it was
strangulation
and you just scrolled down all my notes
and you were like oh my god you have
somebody knows
yeah i want to see what the deal was i
went through that ladies book today
catherine casey's book today and i just
went down there like writing down all
this stuff about like the victims and
stuff like that you know because like i
said that's what i wanted to do all
right
so um yeah so let's uh get a little bit
into this like i said i want to do all
the victims and stuff
first and then at the end we'll kind of
get into
uh some of the suspects some of the
people that were convicted for various
things and [ __ ] like that
got to get this alcohol rolling get the
alcohol gotta get this
out we're all rolling because man my my
i'm i'm sleepy as [ __ ]
well we woke up kind of early i mean
i wanted to sleep every saturday morning
i'm literally kind of like man i'm gonna
sleep in and then i [ __ ] remember
yeah as soon as the sun comes up i go
boink
yep so by the like 6 37 i'm sorry i got
a cat running
run run across well yeah that's another
thing too because she's out of
she was out of her favorite treats so
now we're on the backup treats and she
was clearly
not very happy about it thank you
bridgette
what to say it says been waiting for
this episode more in-depth one
okay there we go yeah well hopefully
that's what this is but yeah she knows
that's not the right treats
yeah she so she's just i mean she'll eat
them but then she's like climbing all
over us looking at us like what are you
trying to pull i know these are not my
kitty crack
she likes those little temptations
they're called temptations
what the [ __ ] did they put it like crack
man they know the difference between
that treat yeah you try to give her
other ones she's like
that's not cool i bought all different
kinds of ones i bought ones from aldi i
bought ones from chewy i bought like all
different kinds the only other
like treats that she likes as much as
temptations are those sheba
meat sticks yeah she loves oh my god she
loves this yeah some of them
some of the the treats were given now
actually came from uh listeners
that's right i had a big stockpile of
those yeah and so she's getting those
for right now she eats them
but she tells me that's wrong it's not
the right
it's not temptations yeah those are a
good one any kind of temptation
uh different flavors sandra asked how's
beijing doing with her thing
what was it it was her liver yeah yeah
that's bet she's better um she yeah she
seems to be
fine uh she had a thing the other day
where didn't she have to get her little
butt gland
yeah lanced or whatever which happened
yeah yeah yeah
it popped on its own yeah we had to give
her some uh it was pretty gross i had to
give her what do you call it
cat's ass exploded
she had to go on antibiotics yeah poor
babies
this isn't the first time that's
happened to her she's had it happen a
couple of times that ass explodes every
three or four years every three years or
so
i don't know what it is it's apparently
it's it's pretty common like with
cats i guess but yeah i hope pookie
doesn't ever have anything like that but
poor beijing has had it a few times
genetically
it's real disgusting yeah
seth says we have temptations here too
and i agree it is cat crack i don't know
what the [ __ ] they put in there man it's
like
god david june's saying he's never seen
he'd never seen a cat that didn't like
those
temptations i haven't either the chicken
ones oh they like the chicken ones the
barbecue ones the seafood ones
the catnip ones the milk flavored ones i
mean they'll eat any other flavor yeah
i think the chicken and the barbecue
ones are their favorite but they'll eat
and i even bought them for
christmas i bought ones that were like
they were turkey and sweet potato on the
inside and
those two oh and they love those too
there's something about the filling
yeah it's got crack in it yeah tammy
says yeah my cat loves temptation
they all do yep what are you putting in
their temptations whoever owns
temptation you try to give them
something else they're like
no that's not it it's not as good that's
not it yeah they're [ __ ] funny man
that's what it is i'm sure temptations
probably gets letters every single day
like what the [ __ ] are you putting in
here
special ingredient i know yeah see so
now everybody's like that was like
worried that we hadn't got our new side
tracks there you go it's like a
temptations cat treats yeah what the
[ __ ] you put in there because
cats will just like eat the [ __ ] out of
them it's crack it's gotta be yeah
she'll eat those rather than like you
give her regular wet food and she'll
kind of be like man she'll like
eat a bite and then turn her nose up at
it but you know you open
you shake the [ __ ] temptations box
she's right there man
she'll leave it like normal she'll even
like knock it knock the box over and try
to get in there
like try to open the [ __ ] little
thing in the middle of the night she's
trying to [ __ ] open the damn box
she's like you can hear it
[Laughter]
i gotta get up four more she's like my
plate is empty
yeah her little treat plate
all right so let's kind of go um through
this this is
you know victim somebody's i'm gonna go
like sort of um
chronologically but not exactly
chronologically because sometimes people
would disappear and the bodies wouldn't
be found a lot later
um you know so i don't really want to
like be confusing like that but
we'll get into it now here's something
that the wikipedia page doesn't
say um a little while
a few months actually before the first
victim
disappeared there was an incident
in april of 1971. now there was a 16
year old girl
uh unnamed in the press obviously she
was a minor
now she was sunbathing on east beach in
galveston i think it was a tuesday and
she'd skipped school for that day
um she would later report that she was
approached
by a white male who basically forced her
into his car
drove her to the south jetty which was
kind of secluded and started beating her
up and trying to rape her
now she got away uh obviously and she
reported the [ __ ] to police
but the police were just kind of like ah
probably some drunk you know how is this
1971.
okay boys will be boys i imagine them
saying
well i think they were just going like
what do you want us to do about it
we don't have it they do that kind of
[ __ ] a lot
it's kind of sad what do you want us to
do about it i mean you know
what do you expect we don't have him in
custody what do you look like
we didn't kill you so he couldn't have
been serious that's what they think
that's probably yeah that's probably
what they were thinking
and it's like i know it's very easy to
say in hindsight because look it's
you know i hate to say but you know if
you're a girl or a woman there's
you have creepy dudes approaching you
all the time you can't cast yourself
20 years into the future and you know
this guy is a serial killer and oh if i
had known
you know i would have [ __ ] killed him
right then and solved all his you know
and then we wouldn't have had all these
problems later on
so it's very easy to like in hindsight
because you know that all this [ __ ]
happened later
that hey maybe this was one of the
serial killers
but they didn't really do anything about
it at the time like i said it was the
early 70s
galveston was kind of um it's weird
because galveston seemed like for a
while it was kind of going in the
atlantic city kind of route like it
would
you know it was kind of like you know
all the rich people would come and there
was like all these like
cool nightclubs and casinos and [ __ ] but
then after a while it was just kind of
everyone just was just kind of like man
they went to vegas and
went elsewhere um so it's still like
apparently a really beautiful area but i
think at the time it wasn't it didn't
have a real high population
like a lot of people lived there
seasonally like you know they would come
down from the north and they had houses
down there
but there weren't that many people that
lived there year round i think you know
maybe
i want to say 60 000 i could be totally
wrong about that in the early 1970s and
it was supposed to be like a real safe
area you know
so nobody really thought too much about
it they just thought of some creepy
drunk guy
probably not though because uh not too
not too long later only like two months
later
uh june 17th 1971. there's a little 13
year old girl
named collette wilson now
she had been at music practice i think
like band practice i think she played a
clarinet if i'm uh
remembering it correctly now she had
been at
it was like a band practice or you know
uh something
like our concert or something like that
now her band director
uh dropped her off uh at the corner of
county road 99 and highway 6.
now he dropped her off there and then
her mom was supposed to come pick her up
right so the mom and
three of collett's siblings were in the
car and they were coming to pick her up
from the time that she was dropped off
from the time
uh to where her mom showed up in the car
six minutes
but when the mom showed up in the car
collett wasn't there
so there was a six minute gap where
somebody took her
so he pulled up in a car and forced her
in yeah and this is
this is so horrible like can you imagine
if this happened
because this is all i would think about
so the mom claire
she pulls up to the spot where she's
supposed to pick up collette right
and she said at the time she's like oh
well i saw a man
you know sitting in a car that was kind
of off at the side of the road but she
didn't think anything about it at the
time because why would you
yeah because she didn't know her
daughter was missing the first thing she
thought
because sometimes she would tell
collette because collette had a friend
that only lived
like a block or two away from this
corner and she's like hey you know if
i'm late or if i don't show up after a
few minutes then just go to your
friend's house and wait and then i'll
know to go pick you up there so that's
what she thought had happened
she thought oh well maybe i'm later than
i thought and she went to the friend's
house so she went to the friend's house
but she wasn't there
she's probably in that dude's car right
in front of her that's i know and it's
like if
can you imagine if that was your
daughter and you did that and then like
you just saw the car and you didn't
think anything about it because why
would you
13 yeah client because
you know you wouldn't think about it it
was just like a dude in a car you
wouldn't think anything was weird
you know and it's like oh my daughter's
not there oh she must have just gone to
her friend's house because i took too
long to get here dude [ __ ] ran up
there and [ __ ] threatened her with
something
scared her so bad she got in the car
i imagine that's probably what happened
um but yeah it's really scary
so i mean after uh the mom she went to
the friend's house she called all her
other friends she's like you know where
is she obviously she's like she wasn't
she went to the cops uh you know and
told them what happened and again the
cops didn't really take it all that
seriously even though the little girl
was only 13.
they were kind of like ah she's just a
runaway she'll come back it happens all
the time
which it might maybe like i know a lot
of teenagers do run away
um but her family were just like nah
it's just like
she wouldn't do that she's not like that
um
you know and we know her better than you
do so obviously something is wrong
uh but like i said the cops didn't
really uh take it seriously
um but perhaps they should have like i
said i'm jumping ahead her body was
actually not found
until five months later
they found her near the attic's
reservoir
near the body of one of the later
victims which i'll get into in a little
bit
this is so sad to me too not only the
whole thing about the mom seeing the
dude in the car
maybe that dude in the car didn't have
anything to do with the disappearance
but
him the fact of him sitting there the
fact that there was only a six minute
window from when the band director
dropped the little girl off
to when her mom showed up i kind of feel
like that dude in the car was probably
had something to do with it but you know
i don't know um
so that's horrible like you're [ __ ]
if that was your kid you would just like
spend the rest of your life
like why didn't i go say anything to
that dude or whatever
um so when they found her remains which
were
skeletal at this point her dad
had to identify her dad was a dentist
and her dad
had done like all her fillings and stuff
right
and he recognized his work
isn't that horrible it's like it was
really horrible to read about i was just
like oh
can you i can't imagine like how you
would go through that
but yeah so that's what happened was
this again 1971
right yeah uh
yeah all right so the next girl
to disappear was
14 year old brenda jones
it's all the same victimology right
the right age you notice that yeah
well most of them were teenagers like
young teenagers there were a few later
that were a little bit older like 19
but he probably didn't know they were a
little bit older though depending on
what they look like
this is somebody who likes young young
girls
yeah i think it's the same guy at this
stage like you're talking about all the
70s one
yeah it just sounds like the same guy
well they're speculating that these 11
that happened in the 70s were probably
the same guy just because
the circumstances were very similar the
way they were killed was very so the way
their bodies were found was very simple
he's probably not real physically
intimidating so he goes for younger ones
because he can intimidate those
um comply that's probably what it is
yeah so brenda jones
uh 14 years old was last seen on july
1st 1971.
now she was actually on that particular
day she was actually going to see her
aunt in the hospital because her aunt
had broken her leg
her family was poor and they didn't have
a car so
she usually took the bus she took the
bus to the hospital she visited her aunt
everything was fine
she took the bus back home several
people on the bus and the driver said
that she was on the bus and that she got
off
at her regular stop which was only a
block or two from her house
after she got off the bus she
disappeared
um so the next day i think it was only
the next day
her body was found in galveston bay near
pelican
island now when police first arrived on
the scene
for whatever reason because i've seen
pictures of her um
they thought that she was older than she
was they thought that she was 20.
i don't know why um but then another
officer arrived on the scene and he
recognized her
like he knew who she was um he's like no
that's brenda she's only 14.
she was a student at holy rosary school
actually
fun fact the first african-american
catholic school in texas
so she was found nude
her wrists and ankles had been bound
together with the laces
from her roman style sandals she had
some of those sandals very popular in
the 70s that
laced all the way up to your knees yeah
she was wearing those um
yes so she had been bound with the laces
from those
her underwear had been stuffed into her
mouth postmortem
no one's really sure why um coroner
stated that brenda had been abducted and
kept alive all night
probably been killed by manual
strangulation
sometime around sunrise on the same day
that her body was found
uh he also concluded that her body had
been dumped into the water from a boat
or a pier
because there didn't appear to be a lot
of uh you know
her body wasn't really beat up or
anything
um now interestingly
there really didn't nobody saw any
connection because you have to think
that collette wilson the first murder
victim
she wasn't beat up she um i said she
wasn't beat up
no but it was manual strangulation yeah
yeah okay
because i was just thinking he didn't
throw her in the water she didn't drown
did she
no okay no she was strangled um
even though collette wilson had
disappeared her body had not yet been
found at this stage
um also because collette wilson was
white
and brenda jones was black um
i guess nobody really thought to connect
the two crimes
even though the circumstances were
similar it's the same dude
yeah of course it is yeah like now we
it's obviously but they weren't really
like i said they hadn't found collett
wilson wilson's body when
brenda jones disappeared so at this
point they just had a disappearance with
which they were saying oh she's a
runaway and then they find a body
you know what i mean so she was brenda
jones was like the first body found even
though she wasn't the first one taken
they thought it was a different dude
because
you know serial killers usually hunt
within their own ethnic group yep but
not always
not always not always and not in this
case they you know they
they'll uh they take targets of
opportunity
he might have just seen her and goes
well she's cute i'll take her too
you know i think that's exactly what's
going on i think he just kind of took
anyone that would
that he could uh overpower that he could
get to get into his car that was just
walking along
yep um because most of these girls were
just kind of like walking along with a
friend
you know as we'll get into later well as
we'll get into in a minute
um three sets of them were taken in
pairs
like you know what i mean when they were
just hanging out with their friends like
in the daytime
so yeah scary but any survivors from
those
no nope i think maybe more than one guy
or maybe one guy with a gun
could be itch could be yeah yeah
but yeah so as i said no one is thinking
serial killer at this point and like i
said this is the early 70s uh
ted bundy hadn't been caught yet so it
was a morning
serial time yeah serial killer was not
really
in the public lexicon at this stage i
guess
like people knew that this [ __ ] happened
but i don't think they were
thinking about it the same way that we
would think about it
all right so the next uh two girls
to disappear were rhonda johnson
uh who all her friends called renee and
sharon shaw um
renee was 14 and sharon was 13.
now they were last seen august 4th
1971. on this particular day
um they had dropped by a kind of a
popular
teen hangout around the area of gal
galveston called the wicks
ski school um you know you went there to
water ski
both of the girls were really really
into you know surfing beach
water skiing is a lot of people that
lived in galveston works the very beach
beachy community so they go to the ski
school
uh because they wanted a water ski and
the owner said well i can't take the
boat out today like the water's too
choppy
so at that point the two girls
left and started walking uh
along sea wall boulevard toward the
beach they seemed kind of bummed out
because they really wanted to water ski
that day
um but
no one knows if they just like walked to
the beach and got taken there or if they
were hitchhiking to go somewhere else
um i think there was at least one
witness that said they saw them
hitchhiking but i don't know how
credible that is
um but they did actually were actually
known to hitchhike which a lot of people
did in the early 70s because like i said
it was a different time
people were a lot more i don't want to
say trusting or naive or something like
that but
it was just something that a lot of
people did and they didn't really think
much about it
so these two girls were no different in
that regard so they may have been
hitchhiking or they may have just been
walking
um so these two go missing
just as in the prior cases um these two
girls were also first considered
runaways
in particular because these two
as i said very very into surf culture
beach culture they had talked
numerous times even though they were
only 14 and 13 years old
um that they wanted to run off to
california that's where the good surfing
was that's where all the surfers hung
out it's like they they kind of wanted
to go to california
um and you know be in that whole scene
so even a lot of their friends at the
time you know the cops are just kind of
like oh they must have taken off to
california because they talked about it
a lot
um and even some of their friends it was
an interview like a pretty extensive
interview with um
one of their friends uh you know from
the time
in that in that deliver us book and she
said even we thought that
we thought that they oh they i guess
they just took off for california like
they were always talking about
you know what i mean yeah that was that
wouldn't happen
what happened to him so they actually
weren't found
until much later um renee was found
in early january of 1972
and sharon was found february 17th of
1972.
um they were both skeletons by this
point both of their skeletons were found
on the banks of an overflow ditch
running off taylor bayou
east of i-45 about 30 miles north of
galveston
this is the 12 year old and a 13 year
old this is a 13 year old and a 14 year
old
they were both taken at once yeah um
so this is actually kind of near an
affluent community called shore acres
so as i said sharon's remains were found
about six weeks after
renee's and they were about a half a
mile apart
no evidence of trauma found on either
set of remains
no gunshots no anything like that how
rotten were they
they were skeletons skeletons okay um so
cause of death on this one uh was a
homicide but uh cause of death was
undetermined because
yeah or smothering or something like
that usually if they can't find any
trauma in the body it's usually
smothering or sometimes strangulation
although usually that hyoid bone will
give away strangulation but
if they couldn't find that bone or
whatever then that might have been the
case
but they're saying it was a murder but
obviously
because where the bodies were dumped but
they couldn't determine exactly
uh how they had died they're going how
could they do this to kids what man
how could they do that to even adults
you know how could anyone do that to
anybody i said the only
you know what it's like i kind of feel
like i okay i could do that to somebody
that
was a [ __ ] horrible person like you
know what i mean was was a serial kill i
could take a serial killer and i could
torture them and kill them sure but
especially if they came out for somebody
you knew
well yeah that's what i mean um you know
so i i don't i wouldn't have any problem
i wouldn't be [ __ ]
you know all thing about it yeah because
they [ __ ] have it coming
yeah innocent people [ __ ] that
ritualized combat between [ __ ]
men [ __ ] warfare [ __ ] this and
that yeah i'm all about that that's the
ultimate contact sport
[ __ ] that's part of ptsd is it right
no
[Laughter]
no but it's it's like it goes back to
that [ __ ] right there
the the weird thing the weird thing
about these dudes is that they're
sexualizing murder
and i don't understand how the [ __ ] you
can kill a totally helpless person
that's done nothing wrong to you
it's a lot more understanding when this
is an enemy this is somebody who means
that's what i mean i think
most people could do that yeah i mean
that
seems really natural like to defend i'll
hear things all time and come
common parts oh this is hate all this
hatred and
hate is a powerful emotion and everybody
and when it comes to warfare tribal
warfare
conflict going back to the [ __ ]
beginnings of humanity
hate kind of ran the show you know
um it kind of helped human progress
technology was all an emerging property
of
people fighting because they hated each
other hate is kind of a good survival
mechanism
you hate people who are trying to hurt
you that's usually what it means well
like i said there's nothing wrong with
that that's a very natural human natural
human emotion
you just gotta you gotta realize
my advice to the audience is uh make
sure you're not being manipulated by
false information
because authorities will tell you to
hate
other groups not because they're your
enemy because it's their enemy
you're always trying to get your under
underlings to do your dirty work for you
you know and uh you know be me being
ex-infantry and stuff
we kind of knew that the enemies that
they'd send us after weren't really our
enemies personally
that's why they were trying to make the
warfare a little more civilized
go see uh my uh our uh
apocalypse now video you can't make war
more civilized it's always uncivilized
it's always tribal warfare
the whole thing is a [ __ ] crazy
experiment but these guys here
this is sexual murder well they're just
plucking random little girls off the
street yeah
and just they're getting men too it's
just that we're not talking about those
offenders
mostly it's mostly heterosexual guys
perverts they don't have any comp they
don't have any confidence around
full-grown women some of them
so they're going after these real young
ones because it's easy picking
they feel powerful next to these girls
but you must have got to be a [ __ ]
scumbag
uh yeah you know and then like it's bad
enough just to rape some chick
but then you're gonna kill her
afterwards so you don't get caught
or maybe you like that too that's part
of the whole thing i think it is perfect
you know
it would have to be i just wanted to i
wanted to give a shout out to
jay marcus she said that um she had a
hard night her kitty just died
oh no that's too bad i'm sorry
my mother was crying right here and said
she used to sit next to her and like
listen to the show on saturday
what happened to her well me out i don't
know okay
that made me sad but i had so i'm so
sorry to hear that it's like
i can't imagine tyler said uh didn't
they make a movie about this with
jeffrey d morgan yeah they did i
mentioned it at the beginning i think it
came out in 2011.
um it's highly highly fictionalized um i
don't even think they used any of the
names of the victims and stuff which i
can see why they did that
it's kind of similar but this is all the
[ __ ] that happened in there it's not
really
uh related to anything particularly that
happened but they made the movie like to
kind of
up the um you know the profile of the
texas killing field so
hoping that somebody would remember some
[ __ ] so they could solve some of the
ones that hadn't been solved
yeah i just can't i can't relate to this
wasting perfectly good young people
just to fulfill some kind of a [ __ ]
momentary sexual [ __ ]
urge you know what i mean it's funny
versus a piece of garbage or something
that's well actually like i was
listening to the time suck thing about
this which actually is very very good
and like really detailed and he makes
jokes in there about to like not about
the victims obviously but um
that was exactly what he said he said
you know think about think of how much
better the world would be
if you know these dudes that
just you know that kill people just for
like a fleeting
sexual urge which is all it is if they
just [ __ ] off themselves or just went
and jerked off and then just
[ __ ] went back to their house and
didn't [ __ ] do anything about it
anymore
it's like yeah that would be nice if
that happened everybody just leave her
leave everybody else alone [ __ ]
especially little girls
god damn it all right so
right around this time here's another
thing that's not on the wikipedia page
um they came up with a suspect actually
so now this suspect was named harry
lanham
he was a 24 year old wrecker driver
now he got arrested in april of 1972
along with a friend of his a vietnam
veteran by the name of anthony napa
junior
for murdering 21 year old linda fay
sutherland whose body had been found
along
uh county road 89 in november of 1971.
what they pieced together had happened
according to witness accounts and
whatever
it looked like linda's car had broken
down like in a parking lot
and uh the two men had picked her up in
their tow truck
um because like i said one of them was a
tow truck driver
now unlike all of the previous
texas killing fields murders uh linda
was actually found
fully clothed though she had been tied
up with her own pantyhose and she had
been beaten
also it looked like they had like there
was some shotgun pellet stuff like
like an injury to her shoulder huh she
tried to run away and they shot at her
yeah
um so so they caught these two
[ __ ] um now once these two [ __ ]
were in jail
harry lanham confessed to all the
killing fields murders that had occurred
up to this point
however the more they questioned him the
more the police
didn't buy it um i'm guessing because a
lot of the details he gave up didn't
jibe with like the crime
scenes and [ __ ] like that uh for
whatever reason the cops did not charge
him with any of them
um and actually one of the um
wilson's father tom uh
who you know got very uh into the
investigation
uh as it went on he actually went and
interviewed the dude too
and he came away from that thinking i
think that dude was lying
i don't think he did it but i mean
there's no doubt that he did that one
that 21 year old woman that they picked
up in their tow drug him at his friend
and drove around with her and raped and
killed her um but he's like i don't
think they did all the other ones
um you know the little girls and the
cops apparently didn't think he did
either
however him and his friend were were
actually convicted
of that one murder um
napa got 50 years harry lanham got
25 years for killing linda sutherland um
happily harry lanham got killed only a
few months after he was sentenced
uh when he tried to escape from jail
with a homemade knife and the cop shot
him
so we've been back good riddance he's
gotten killed a couple months
before release well yeah
that probably would have been better so
he would have liked saturday morning
no well still i mean dudes like that
it's just that it's better that they're
dead
for it's better for everyone involved
you know what i mean yes it's nice if
they suffer
and it would be good if they did but if
they don't if they just die
i'll take that too as long as they're
not running around
so the next victim was gloria gonzalez
now she was a little bit older she was
19.
um she was a bookkeeper at a houston
kroger grocery store um she was last
seen october 28
1971. uh i guess she was walking home
from work like back to her apartment she
had an apartment on
jacqueline street in houston uh her
roommate actually reported her missing
when she didn't come home
um later on about it was a little less
than a month later
uh her headless and decomposing remains
were found near attic's reservoir uh
pretty much the same area where collette
wilson's body had been found
now interestingly okay so the head
was separate from the body but the
coroner determined that probably animals
had done that
the weird thing about it though was that
the skull was pretty much completely
deflected
like you know decomposed whereas the
body still had some flesh on it
which they thought was very weird i'm
not really sure why i don't know if the
conditions were slightly different from
where the you know the
body and the skull were found or what
have you um
cause of death seemed to be ligature
strangulation because they did find it
was like a four inch piece of wood
and it was kind of cinched around her
neck with a two foot cotton cord
so you know they use that to strangle
her now
this is actually how collett wilson
ended up being found as i said she was
the
first one taken but wasn't found until
five months later
so when they found gloria gonzalez's
skeleton
they actually found some other teeth
um you know at the same site and then
they got confused because he was trying
to like the coroner was trying to put
the teeth into this
mandible and they didn't fit so he was
kind of like well
whose teeth are these then um at which
point they're like there must be another
individual out here
so they went and looked again and that's
when they found collette wilson's
body so like i said she had she had uh
disappeared five months prior
but that's how they ended up finding her
now the next one
this is interesting because this is
comes up on the wikipedia page
but this was uh this victim was not
mentioned in the book so i don't know
i don't think this is one of the
canonical 11 but it is
for sure weird and it happened in the
same area and it might be connected to
the other ones
this is a 12 year old girl named alison
craven
she was last seen november 9th 1971.
now she had been home by herself
and her mom went out to run some errands
she was gone for about an hour
and then she came home and her daughter
was
gone now their apartment was near i-45
now police later ended up finding
alison's partial remains in a field
nearby
they found two of her hands um and
some teeth and the bones from one arm
they found the rest of her skeleton on
february 25th 1972
in uh purland i guess per land so
whatever it is
um which is also near i-45 about five to
ten
miles away from her apartment where they
assumed that she was taken from
i don't know if she left the apartment
while her mom was gone or somebody came
in the apartment and took her i don't
know
so that's like i said that's not usually
one of the canonical 11 but it is listed
uh as one of the related murders no car
missing or anything huh
well she was only 12. okay she was only
12. that's right these all sound like
vehicle abductions
somebody pulls up on them with a car
maybe pulls a pistol on him tells him to
get in
i see what it sounds i think that's
probably what's you know what's
happening
just funny is like that's [ __ ] some
bold [ __ ] you don't hear about that
happening much anymore maybe it's
because there's so many damn cameras at
the intersections
yeah to where they don't feel
comfortable
pulling a gun at some on somebody from a
from you know
in public from a car and telling them to
get in maybe because they wouldn't
they just run well yeah i feel like
those people
would be like yeah no not getting in
there bud
a little kid might though yeah
yeah you know they think a gun is a
magical wand you wave it at somebody and
pull the trigger and they're instantly
killed
man it's [ __ ] hard to shoot a [ __ ]
running person in a close range
especially with the [ __ ] pistol
just run zigzag yeah run zig zag run
fast as you can if that dude's got a
revolver man he's probably gonna burn up
all six rounds not let anyone
take you to another location never never
ever anyone take you to another ever
let anyone
you fight like hell it's a it's a fate
worse than death make them
make them shoot you do not go do not let
anybody take you anywhere
because you're gonna just get in the car
honey it'll be all right let me i'm
gonna put these
handcuffs on you it'll be all right now
i'm gonna let you go and i'm done
he's not gonna let you go no [ __ ] that
you know he's gonna [ __ ] torture you
yeah and then kill you yep
so i mean you might as well just get
shot
well i mean honestly just run just run i
mean that's what i'm saying
yeah if you run zigzag yeah he might
shoot you but he might not kill you
yeah and it's better than what he's
planning on doing the worst thing that
could happen while you're zig-zagging is
she he [ __ ] connects with
and you get shot and you die on the spot
or maybe later
you die that's a lot better than being
[ __ ] tortured for a month or two days
or [ __ ] six hours yeah
you guys cause you're still death is
still death you guys have read about
some of these cases you don't want some
of this [ __ ] happening might as well
[ __ ] make him [ __ ] kill you yeah
early on
yeah scary all right so the next one
this was another
pair of best friends debbie ackerman who
was 15
and maria johnson also 15. these two
girls were last seen november 15th
1971. uh they were best friends
um also very active in galveston's beach
and surf culture
like i said like a lot of people in
galveston were a very beachy community
uh
debbie was actually she was born in
galveston her parents were german
immigrants
uh maria had only been there about a
year
on the weekend of their disappearance uh
debbie had been wanting to stay over at
maria's house which she did quite often
like i said they were best friends who
were always staying in each other's
houses um
it was a holiday weekend i believe it
was uh i don't know if it was some kind
of holiday it was thanksgiving i
wasn't late enough to be thanksgiving i
don't know but they said it was like a
three-day weekend
so uh so she stayed at her like she
initially asked her mom hey can i stay
over at maria's house all weekend and
her mom was like no you need to stay
here and help me clean the house and the
kid was like [ __ ] that and then she went
and asked her dad
and her dad said sure you can go in
which case probably the parents argued
but whatever
so uh so she goes to maria's house
they spend the weekend kind of hanging
out maria's house they go to the mall
like to get one of their boyfriends a
present or something like that
monday they were seen uh
at a baskin-robbins ice cream shop there
were two girls that were working there
and the two girls that were working
there said that they saw
debbie and maria accepting a ride
from a dude in a white van with a piece
sticker
on the back window yeah and that was the
last time
the piece symbol was gonna was
counteracting the fact that he was in a
white van
yeah because white van is just like
molester molester
serial killer i mean in white van that's
like the
the vehicle of choice maybe that wasn't
a meme back then
i guess it wasn't no i mean seriously is
it
nobody can even i and i wonder sometimes
too like as time has gone on
like how much the sales of white vans
have
been depleted because everybody
associates like a white van with [ __ ]
cereal
that hasn't been affected at all white
vans that's
all your [ __ ] utility and work vans
are white
uh because you know state agencies and
companies it's the cheapest color it's
the toughest color
the most bulk purchases you know yeah
they buy them for fleet vehicles and
then they're resold
you know that it's easier on the air
conditioning in the inside and
everything now vans are
tend to be white you know yeah the
reason why serial killers happen because
there's a lot of used ones out there
yeah yeah like crown victorious
excellent cars man they're [ __ ]
everywhere though and like you said
because so many white vans are used as
work trucks
yeah maybe a lot of times they can be
like incognito because they're like hey
i'm just like that's right
in your meter that's all blends right in
from the electric company well you know
what i bet you had a white truck
and you had some ladders on the top of
it and
and maybe something looks like you can
it's like camouflage
yeah you don't even notice those things
yeah because they just think about them
yeah it's a cable guy yeah you don't
even notice it
you see many of those every time you go
out you don't even notice them
well yeah [ __ ] we see them around here
all the time because like long cruise or
amazon prime
like i think the amazon prime ones are
great though it says amazon prime on it
yeah
um yeah so they were seen getting into
this white van it's just like a
clipboard
if you've got a clipboard in your hand
in your hand maybe a cup of coffee
and maybe a hard hat and a tie you can
walk around all day long nobody asks you
a [ __ ] question and you could be btk
for all you can
be decaying the [ __ ] out of this place
but you got a cup of coffee and a
clipboard and a hard hat and a tie
yeah short sleeve [ __ ] frickin
important that's doing some [ __ ]
serving
around yeah if your little mustache a
white do with a mustache luigi in your
ass around
like luigi luigi
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah serpent surfer says that and they
can put a mattress in the back serial
killer shag and wife yeah
that's exactly why you can you can stack
victims back there like cord would
yeah horrifying um so yeah
two days later uh the bodies were found
with shoelaces uh you know bound up with
shoelaces
nude from the waist down and turner's
bayou maria was found first
debbie was found several hours later on
the same day
it appeared that both girls had died
from gunshot wounds to the head
so they had been shot not strangled
that's a different that's a difference
um
i don't know though because he was they
were bound in the same way so i kind of
feel like this was probably the same
dude but he was just like changing [ __ ]
up
maybe maybe maybe he had a fetish thing
he wanted to know what was like to shoot
him louis hernandez says crown vic was
my first car
crown big crown vics are excellent cars
that and that damn mercury grand marquis
that's the [ __ ]
upscale version that's the pimpin
version of the crown vic
but like all your cop cars and all your
your wedding columns your all your
[ __ ]
cab you know your taxi cabs they're all
crown vics all your old men cars are
crown vics
they're [ __ ] everywhere that [ __ ]
ford modular engine in there and all
that [ __ ]
i can work on those things man they're
easy to work on parts like water
they the thing is the connotation though
is that they're just so many of them
that
you know put divorce dual exhaust on
their man
turn it into a marauder maybe go 5.4
liter
yeah you can do all kinds of cool [ __ ]
with that no way i'm going down
getting sidetracked well i mean the
thing about it though it's if all you
want is a car that's going to be
relatively
cheap to fix and it's going to be pretty
reliable yeah and you don't really care
what it looks like
even cheaper and even more reliable they
look they can look good if you [ __ ]
got one painted and it
and it's got a nice interior even more
reliable than a ford taurus
and cheaper than a ford taurus but their
v8s you know they don't get
great gas mileage but you can live with
them they never break
you know the [ __ ] heavy duty
alternators that are cheap you can get
rebuilt ones
[ __ ] autozone's got everything for
the crown vic
and like they're just flooded here in
the u.s
flooded with spare parts they're trying
to get rid of those spare parts
[ __ ] everywhere those cars are
[ __ ] they're just built like [ __ ]
tanks
tanks yeah proven especially the later
generations all our cop cars are still
crown vicks
beeznes says my first car was a vw
dasher yeah
mine was at toyota tercel
[Laughter]
that was a [ __ ] it was manual
transmission holy [ __ ] man
hernandez says that yep mexicans and
crown vics go hand in hand
you're [ __ ] right well they it's a
good deal man excellent car cheap prices
you can keep them running forever well
yeah like i said if you don't want to
pour your whole entire [ __ ] life
savings into the car and you want to
make sure it gets you from place to
place without breaking down every five
minutes
oh and [ __ ] the you can get you can
get the uh mercury uh
you can get mercury um what do you call
it what the [ __ ]
i just named it get the [ __ ] the
mercury version of it
the interiors they're [ __ ] plush man
[ __ ]
same thing with [ __ ] uh lincoln town
car it's that same
basic part fancy you can make a [ __ ]
just a
pimp ride out of one of those just
[ __ ] plush interiors and [ __ ] you can
if you know what you're doing you can
really deck a crown vic out and you can
get a user for nothing like 500 bucks
for another
kind of like what i did to your taurus
yeah but it crowned
i was looking for a crowd vic remember
yeah we couldn't find one we just got
the taurus because it was only fourteen
hundred dollars
yes i mean it needed a little bit of
work but not much tires and it needed i
think we put another 500 bucks into it
and it's still [ __ ] running
distributor and we really haven't done
too much it's got like a little problems
but nothing that really keeps it from
replace the air conditioning compressor
compressor air compressor
yeah yeah it's a you know it's it's been
a pretty reliable car of course i can't
believe i just said that out loud
because now i probably jinxed it
yeah now next time we drive it it's just
going to rarely drive it now
i know that's what i mean i don't drive
it i used to drive it all the time he
knows the marauder
yeah yeah the marauder was a good
addition
yeah all right so let's see now we're in
1973.
next victim was a 16 year old girl named
kimberly pitchford she was last seen
january 3rd 1973.
uh she was at dobby high school she had
actually
done her classes there and then i think
she had like after school what do they
call that
uh not suspension but um what is that
when you have to get when you're in
trouble and you go after [ __ ] yeah yeah
it's called
you know like you're detecting there
yeah so i was like you know like the
breakfast club whatever
says he used to drive him and the guy's
talking about the police uh the police
interceptors granthar was a cop i
believe
but uh yeah police interceptors they
were good and like i said you could
scale up to the plush interiors too
the aftermarket was [ __ ] cheap you
could get really good [ __ ] interiors
for it
300 bucks you could put a whole new
interior in one
okay go ahead we're talking cars now
next we're gonna be talking guns
we gotta get back to true crime guys
yeah yeah he's seen how many notes i
have so yeah just kind of like gotta get
it right
so yeah so she had gone to classes then
she had detention and then she had
a driver's ed uh test she had a test for
driver's ed
later on that evening at the same high
school
so she leaves high school um the high
school at about 6
p.m and disappears
her body was found two days later in a
ditch
22 miles away from her high school uh
she was not found nude uh she was still
clad in the dress
she'd last been seen it i think it was
like red and blue she had also
died by ligature strangulation
the next ones to disappear another pair
brooks bracewell who was 12
and georgia gear who was 14. last seen
september 6
1974.
now they were seen at a convenience
store called
you totem off of i don't know why it's
called that that doesn't sound like a
convenience store to me that sounds like
something else um off of 517 and i-45
they were reported missing by their
parents when they didn't show up
at mcadams junior high school for
classes now
there was one witness i don't know if
this is credible or not one witness
reported because apparently they had
skipped school that day these are little
kids
12 and 14. one witness said that they
had seen them playing football
with a group of unidentified men near
alvin texas
don't know if that's true or not might
have been the other people might have
been other girls
another witness said they'd seen the
girls hitchhiking that day
which maybe because like i said a lot of
girls that age did that back then
it wasn't that unusual so they
disappeared uh nobody knew where they
were for
a couple of years their skulls were
actually found in 1976
it appeared as though they had died from
blunt force trauma
like they had been beaten to death in
the head uh the remainder of their
skeletons were not found until 1981.
next victim was a 12 year old
named suzanne bowers last seen may 21st
1977. she had actually been visiting her
grandparents house which was between the
4000 block of avenue s
and the 3100 block of avenue p this was
10 45 in the morning
so like i said none of these were at
night these were all just little girls
walking to the store walking to their
friend's house which everybody did back
then
you know what i mean so [ __ ] crazy
so she was at her grandparents house and
she was going to
go meet some friends down at stuart
beach so she was going to walk
home which i think was only a mile to
get her bathing suit
and get her bike so she could ride to
the bike because i did because i think
that the beach
was three miles away so she was going a
mile to her house get her bike and then
riding three miles
now interestingly this is super sad too
suzanne had asked her grandfather to
give her a ride
the mile to her house and he said no no
you need the exercise
guess what during that mile she
disappeared
she had been that way like a whole bunch
of times and
this is so [ __ ] sad this was a this
was a detail that she uh
that uh catherine casey brought up in
the book she said that um
when the grandfather died many years
later the last word he said was her name
because he never forgave himself for not
giving her a ride that day
because she disappeared i mean he
couldn't have known like i said
but that would [ __ ] i mean that would
just [ __ ] destroy you i would think
like [ __ ] like that so two years later
her skeletal remains were found in alta
loma texas
her skull also showed evidence of blunt
force trauma
kind of uh infamously i guess good old
henry lee lucas
later claimed to have murdered suzanne
bowers yeah [ __ ] but we all know
how credible anything he should comes
out of his mouth
that dude was larping as a serial killer
he wished he was a serial killer he
killed
like three people okay there's all
people he knew in his family
though yeah um now later he did say that
he killed her but then later he said
yeah i just made that up just to get
guess my perks you could get some ice
cream yeah they wanted to he wanted to
go get milkshake or some [ __ ] or some
mcdonald's or something
so yeah i killed that one too why not
add it on to the
list so yeah xanada's in there what's up
bro
zenith has been it's taken him three
days to even try to get through the
first one-third of [ __ ] uh
of apocalypse now you've got
young dudes they just don't have the
damn attention span you know what i mean
for
for movies you know it's an art form
they can they're yet to appreciate
well as i said it's when when you kind
of grow up it's not entirely their fault
because you have to think that younger
people
yeah grow up yeah where you have
ev everything is you know really fast
and everything you have like all these
windows open and it's like you're doing
this you're doing that and everything's
like really quick edited now you can't
enjoy anything
and then i tried it i tried to get him
on other millions flicks tried to put
him on conan the barbarian the first one
he couldn't get through it i told him
about [ __ ] the other one looking
jeremiah johnson another badass
epic [ __ ] millions flick and he's ah
i don't want to see that
but he wanted to see apocalypse now he
can't get through it i know he can't get
through it
i'm [ __ ] with you i want you know
yeah that's hard
oh my god yeah all right so yeah yeah
it's hard that's what he said yeah yeah
so as i mentioned earlier um these
particular 11 murders not counting
alison craven because they're not sure
if that one's connected or not
a lot of investigators suspect these
particular 11 murders
um that took place in the 1970s were
probably committed by the same dude
and a lot of people think that this
particular dude was
edward harold bell now we'll talk about
him
a little bit later um but he's kind of
like
prime suspect at least for the 70s ones
because like i said there were some in
the 80s and some of the 90s and these
were not all the same
guy this is all a bunch of different
serial killers
now hit this is an interesting case i
this is actually not on the wikipedia
page and it wasn't in the book
but i saw it on a texas killing fields
uh you know
site that kind of had a bunch of [ __ ]
about all the victims and everything
and this i've never seen this tied to
this before
but there was a case that happened in
may of 1978. now the victim here
at least one of them was a 28 year old
woman named karen pretty
now this is weird okay so what ended up
happening was her husband
came home they live in north houston he
came home on may 10 1978
he finds a breakfast like half eaten on
the table waters dripping in the front
bathroom
he goes in the bathroom finds the bodies
of his two sons
seven-year-old scott and five-year-old
mark in the bathtub
they had been drowned his wife was in
the master bedroom
and she had been strangled with a phone
cord now her hands and feet were also
bound with another cord
and she was also submerged underwater in
another bathtub
um she was still wearing a bathrobe had
not been sexually assaulted
kids were in their pajamas they had not
been sexually assaulted either
scott had been strangled and then
drowned
in the tub mark was also drowned
strangled to drown
but he had also been beaten house had
not been robbed
only one drawer was open uh their car
which was a 1978 mercury marquee was
found in an unassigned parking spot and
an apartment at 198 goodson drive
he drove away in it so nobody knows if
this one's connected or not i just found
i just thought that was an interesting
case because i never heard about that
one
um doesn't exactly sound like the same
mo
but it's a home invasion but they didn't
take anything which i think is really
and they didn't rape the woman which
like i said is very very strange
and drowning just seems like a very
weird well he was probably going to
there was one guy yeah he went in there
where they were eating breakfast
he took over he told the woman to tell
the kids to get in the bathroom and hide
and they did
he went he went he was going to go rape
the woman then the the kids started to
make too much noise and
he lost control so he strangled and
drowned the woman and went over there
and finished off the kids
that's way that's what happened there
because i feel like that happened in a
couple of btk cases and didn't that
happen in like some original
nightstalker yeah
or something the kids were too young to
just bolt and run
they they did what they were told they
waited in the bathroom yeah
then he got in there and drowned tried
to drown one of them
the other one resisted he had to beat
that one up and he tried he probably
ended up kind of drowning both of them
at the same time
something like that maybe maybe he
knocked one of them out drowned then
drowned that one
went back got grabbed the one that was
knocked out and then drowned him
yeah crazy yeah he was still this is
something that a weak man
does you know what i mean well that's
why he picks on
women and children is because he's an
he's a nothing
you know and uh he could never overpower
you know a grown man you're talking
about a
weak little men doing this they have
[ __ ] self-image problems
normally they're powerless that's why
they do this yeah
yeah they wouldn't need to do it
otherwise nothing they need to do
because they don't it's a [ __ ] choice
but
it's kind of a power trip to them though
because that's the only time they can
ever get anything done
yeah you know [ __ ] you find the dude
he's probably like five
two didn't weigh anything and [ __ ]
balding or something you know it's
always
some kind of physical inadequacy with
these guys
well yeah just one of the main things
nobody takes seriously
nobody takes them seriously so they have
to prove to themselves that they're
dangerous men they're not dangerous
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's what michael
shaver just said it's called being a
[ __ ] yeah they're [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
all right gonna be a bad [ __ ] go
join delta force
let's see how tough you are then yeah
[ __ ] yeah it's really good snatching
little 12 year old girls off the street
yeah that [ __ ] [ __ ] join the [ __ ]
service and it's just
one huge tough man competition and see
how you stack up against [ __ ] dudes
you can see
you know you know you're gonna be at the
bottom you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
yep if you just think this way you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i definitely agree with that yeah okay
so
here's another one that may be related
may not be related
so michelle garvey was 15 years old
interestingly she was last seen in june
1982 so we're in the 80s now
now she actually was from connecticut um
she supposedly ran away from home
she lived in new london connecticut um
they think maybe she climbed out of her
bedroom window and ran away from home
and was maybe trying to hitchhike
however
uh she turned up dead
in texas in uh on july 1st 1982.
um she actually wasn't identified until
2014 i think like on the reddit like or
the web sleuths
forum they actually uh kind of tracked
down and they
identified her they were able to help
identify her because she had been a jane
doe prior to that time
next one was sandra ramber she was 14.
last seen october 26 1983
she was actually looked like she was
maybe taken from her house or was lured
out of her house
she lived in santa fe texas when her
family got home they found the front
door standing open
biscuits were baking in the oven uh her
purse and coat were still in the house
uh she has never been found damn
but they are assuming that she has
probably been murdered
but they don't know where she is gone
they don't know where she is
next victim hidify who was either 23 or
25 i've seen it listed uh
both ages so i'm not really sure she was
last seen
october 10th 1983. she was a cocktail
waitress and a bartender
she um what ended up happening i guess
was that she um she had been at work and
then she was going to hitchhike to
houston
to visit her boyfriend
she was walking from her parents house i
guess
at the time she disappeared i guess she
was walking to her parents house
she was going to use a phone at a nearby
convenience store
which was actually the same pay phone
that a subsequent
victim would also be taken from so same
pay phone
uh the pay phone of doom that's what
that was
um her body was found this is [ __ ]
horrifying
when a dog carried her skull
to a nearby house dog had been digging
around in the woods found a skull
thought he'd bring it and
show the family he knew little toddler
was like standing on the porch going
what the [ __ ] is that the family's like
what the [ __ ] is that
in fido's mouth there dog absolutely
he's a skull
yeah that [ __ ] this is a human look
like do something about this
call the police this smells like a
person yeah
well yeah dogs aren't dumb they're not
done so that's probably
because you know what i've written about
a lot of you know a handful of cases
where dogs did actually bring human
bones
yeah to a nearby house like an arm or
something they know what a dead person
smells like yeah they know it's not an
animal
look this belongs to you yeah this is
your people
yeah you fix this yeah but yeah so
yes so she vanished uh october 10 1983
her body was not found until april of
1984.
she um looked like she had been beaten
to death
uh the coroner thought with a club or a
bat or something like that
uh she had a lot of like broken ribs uh
blunt force trauma to the head
things of that nature next victim was
laura miller 16 years old
uh probably one of the highest profile
cases because her dad would go on to
form uh equisearch
which um you know was instrumental in
like they they search for missing
persons have turned
up probably like i think it's like 140
150
60 70 bodies uh since then have turned
up some missing people
uh they actually came down they looked
they were involved in the kaylee anthony
case when they still thought that kaylee
anthony was missing uh they came down
and helped with that
so this is probably why this is one of
the higher profile ones
so laura miller was 16. it was september
10th 1984.
she was at the same convenience store
that hidify
had been seen at uh talking on the same
pay phone that 85 been
uh talking on she had also called her
boyfriend whose name was vernon
the convenience store was only a mile
from her house her family had just moved
to a new house in league city 10 days
prior to her disappearance which maybe
was why she had to walk to the
convenience store to his phone i don't
know why
um her family actually again the cops
were kind of like oh maybe she's a
runaway although they were taking
[ __ ] a little bit more seriously at this
point um
a little bit what hold on what time how
much time had separated between this
victim and the other one that was on
that phone
um he had disappeared october 1983
um so it was almost a year yes same dude
yeah it is
well yeah it's the same pay phone yeah i
mean that was that was a regular place
for him he
passed yeah it was uh i i think that on
that um
you know dark minds episode that raven
guy that he didn't talk to
he said yeah it's like fishing where
it's like you go back to the same scene
again yeah he's doing a routine he's
doing a route
cruising around yeah like his checking
his regular spots
yeah two of them appeared in that spot i
kind of feel like as much as they kind
of go on about
you know the transient population
because of all the you know the heavy
industry and stuff i kind of feel like
these might be dudes that kind of live
around there or kind of know the area
because the ones that they caught were
dudes that lived around there or had
been there for a while
you know what i mean this is in the
early 80s yeah this and then we're into
the 80s now 80s yeah
drinking and driving wasn't real heavily
enforced in the early 80s in this in the
south
so he's cruising what day did this fall
on of saturday
or friday i don't know i bet you it was
sometime during the weekend
yeah he's cruising around she was last
night it was september 10th 1984 so i
don't know what day of the week that was
that was i don't know he's cruising
around drinking listening to the radio
and he's checking these spots
yeah kind of like teenage boys would do
the same thing in mississippi cruising
around
checking the normal spots and everybody
is going to these spots
and it's where teenagers are checking
each other out and [ __ ] listening to
music and [ __ ]
swapping from the girls are swapping
from one car to the next and then you
just drive around there's nothing else
to do
yeah back in those days so
driving around in cars and switching
cars and everybody
goes to high school or school or middle
school together whatever because you
know
actually in the south you could drive at
13 with a permit so
especially back in those days so
that was cruising culture yeah serial
killers of that era did the same thing
cruising that's what he's doing justin
says finally i get on for live hello
everyone yeah i think this is maybe the
first time i've seen you on a live
stream so hi
hi justin um okay so
so yeah so she disappears from the same
[ __ ] pay phone
a little less than a year after hidi
disappeared from the same
paper um as i said the cops
you know she was 16 and they're like
well maybe she just ran away
uh her family knew she didn't run away
because she had a really bad seizure
disorder and she had medication for it
that she had to take um and she hadn't
taken it with her she hadn't taken any
of her [ __ ] with her
so they ended up finding her body a
little less than two years later
february 3rd 1986
her body was found only about 60 feet
away
from where the body of hedify had been
found who again had been taken from the
same cell phones they were found like 60
feet apart
um you know but a couple of years
michael says uh
i got my dwi in 1990 they were enforcing
them back then
yeah the [ __ ] and anti-drunk driving
thing was actually a late 80s thing
in the in the south in mississippi i can
remember during the mid
early i can remember up until almost
kind of like the
mid 80s 86 87
people would [ __ ] drive around with
open containers drinking it like it was
not drinking like it was nothing
it wasn't they knew about drunk driving
just there wasn't a lot of people on the
road
in the south and it was just in the
culture to drink and drive at the same
time
especially louisiana louisiana was
bigger
but that's just the way it was back then
yeah i kind of feel like they didn't
really think that i was like
wow i can drive it's okay that's why dwi
i lost [ __ ] came in
into play into the late everybody's
[ __ ]
80s
it was getting ridiculous it's getting
ridiculous yeah everybody's
running you see [ __ ] cars [ __ ]
just
fear and fear and almost running off the
road and then coming back into the lane
and [ __ ]
what i got i got it i got it i got it
yeah just drive around and drink bad
enough we drink and stream
yes we're not hurting anybody yeah
except our own reputations
[Laughter]
it was an older generation for the most
part in our generation you know
but they would drink literally drink
yeah right now
you'll be drinking it in there in the
front putting putting the beer like they
were in a bar
yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah it's a mobile bar
yeah they'd be pouring [ __ ] jack
daniels in their [ __ ] cooks and
[ __ ] straws and [ __ ] and
blaring music and just have fun you know
just i remember it dangerous as [ __ ] but
man this is the [ __ ] 80s man and then
the south no one gave a [ __ ] about
others [ __ ] no one gave a [ __ ] about
others
no let's let's be honest about it no one
really thought about others they just
thought about what they wanted to do and
how cool it was and how cool they were
yeah and it was pretty much it and well
it kind of fit the time it was a high
risk
time uh lots of [ __ ] me
[ __ ] rock music and [ __ ] you know
they're listening to journey and [ __ ]
justin said i remember my dad drinking
and driving work to home was a two-beer
trip
yeah and it was uh
this was happening in the more rural
areas anyway
it was you know small towns and country
and
so it didn't impact society at large
because
society in the main mainstream society
didn't live out there anyway
it was like something out in the outback
australia or something sandra said
uh you can drink here openly in a car
too she's in germany case you guys
didn't know
uh just don't get drunk must stay under
i don't remember
0.2 per milliliter whatever it is yeah
so you can i thought you could in the uk
too but it might i mean because people
were doing it when i
was there in the 90s and no one really
seemed to give much of a [ __ ] about it
mississippi
alabama louisiana
texas certain parts of texas maybe a
little bit tennessee to kentucky
oh no back in the 80s they were [ __ ]
loaded driving
yeah loaded listening to journey and
listening to [ __ ] early iron maiden
and [ __ ]
blasting [ __ ] out the [ __ ] windows
and listening to falco and [ __ ]
yeah i'm a dance rock me on my desk yeah
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
car would be packed with girls and [ __ ]
yeah
girls hanging off girls [ __ ] taking
off the yeah
freaking tight ass [ __ ] jeans [ __ ]
tube tops are [ __ ] taking your time
off i was gonna say teddy washington
everybody
everybody knew everybody knew everybody
bad hair everything mullets yeah [ __ ]
mullets yeah
goodness yeah it's crazy yeah
my drink's empty is it let me make it
you gotta make me another one good
all right okay where was i okay so
uh yeah laura miller um so i'll get a
little bit more into like tim miller's
thing like later on because
there was a thing with him with one of
the suspects and that's kind of like a
whole story unto itself
so at this stage because there had been
you know so many
uh you know bodies found in this area
time this was right around the time
right around 1986
uh when that movie about uh cambodia
came out that was called the killing
fields and that's kind of when the media
picked up on the name and started
calling this place the texas killing
fields didn't really have a name prior
to that um
as i said the stretch of i-45 some
people call it the highway to hell prior
to that
not necessarily because of the bodies
because of all the accidents
but from about 1986 onward uh it started
being referred to as the texas killing
field so that's where the name came from
because that's
i believe that's the year that that
movie came out
now the next one uh this
happened in december thank you she went
missing in uh december 1985.
now this woman was actually a jane doe
for a very very long time they found her
body
uh february 2nd 1986 in a field
in the 3000 block of calder road very
near to where laura miller's body had
been found
at the time 1986 when the body was found
they estimated the woman was 22 to 30
years old about five foot five to five
foot eight
and that she had died either six weeks
or you know to six months prior to being
found
she had been shot in the back with a
small caliber firearm
she was not identified until april of
2009
they used family tree dna so genetic
genealogy same way they caught the
original night stalker
and they discovered that she was a 30
year old woman
named audrey cook so it took them from
1986 when they found the body to 2009
to identify her so she is not a jane doe
anymore her name is audrey cook
she was 30 years old last seen december
1985.
now the next one was a
19 year old young woman named shelly
sykes
now she was last seen may 24th 1986.
she had a job as a waitress at i'm not
sure if i'm pronouncing this
gato's guidos it's a very famous uh
seafood restaurant
uh in galveston uh you know it's kind of
a landmark
so she um really liked working there she
had been working there for a little
while
she left after her shift at about 11 35
pm i believe it was memorial day weekend
so it was kind of crazy around there's a
lot of tourists and [ __ ] like that you
know
going to the beach and whatnot um
she was actually uh her kind of dream
was she wanted to open her own
dance studio she was trying to save up
money to do that because she'd been
doing ballet and jazz and all that kind
of stuff now the night she disappeared
she had actually been talking to her
boyfriend mark and she was going to go
to his house after she got off work
which she did quite often
um so she said she was going to do that
she's like oh i'm kind of tired but yeah
i'll drive out there so
uh unfortunately she never got there
her car was found the following day
stuck in the mud
with blood spatter inside the car
abandoned on the side of an i-45
access road south of the galveston
causeway
now mark her boyfriend and mark's father
obviously became worried when she didn't
show up when she said she was going to
so they
drove what route she would take and they
were the ones that found the car
um they there was actually a single
bare footprint in the mud next to the
car
witnesses later claimed that they had
seen shelley's blue pinto
being pursued by a pickup truck which
eventually ran her off the road
uh they also said that a man got out of
the truck wrapped a shirt around his
hand and started banging on shelly's car
window so he was going to break it
and i guess he did break it and then
dragged her out of the vehicle
this man was described as unshaven with
longish
brown hair dark eyebrows and a quote
unquote angry pout
later witness claimed that there had
actually been two men in the truck
and that one of the men had beaten
shelley before dragging her out of the
pinto
um so later on uh
yeah this this case i'll get into a
little bit later on but um
because there were two people that were
actually convicted of this
although they never found her body
so all they could get them for was
aggravated kidnapping
um because you know they couldn't get
them for murder because they didn't have
they still haven't found her um all that
they found of her they think the family
thought that
they found a white blouse that uh that
they think belonged to her
where one of her uh kidnappers gerald
peter zwarst
he actually drew them a map of where
they had buried her although they didn't
find the body there but they did find a
blouse and the family does believe that
it's hers they're not entirely sure
but as i said her body has still never
been found i'll talk about
those two jackasses later on i think we
have one of the biggest online
crowds of all times right now of ours
yeah
76. we've never broken 100.
i don't think we've ever broke 80.
probably not
no we'll see like i said i think that um
a lot of people have been requesting
this topic so i'm kind of glad that we
finally got around to doing it yeah
well true crime is always real popular
well and like i said i
you know as depressing it is i like
doing the kind of more fun topics
because i feel like i can joke more
i feel a little bit bad like not true
crying it's the most hit
it does though i do feel a little bit
bad making jokes on the true crime ones
yeah i mean i still do it but i feel a
little bit bad if we're just talking
about aliens and [ __ ] i don't know louis
corrected me he says we've been at the
80s a couple of times
okay yeah i never really noticed hey
thanks xander ma'am thank you thanks
[ __ ]
oh thank you thank you thank you thank
you so much yeah that's a hard-working
young man right there
hard working that's 10 very hard earned
dollars yeah from that young man thank
you very much thank you so much
we appreciate all you guys yeah and you
need to [ __ ] watch those movies dude
just kind of just let it wash over you
i'm helping us out at the [ __ ] behind
the scenes build a badass rifle
and he's building a [ __ ] ar-15
[ __ ] dissipator
which is a 80s throwback [ __ ] 16 inch
barrel with a [ __ ]
carbine length gas system with a [ __ ]
a2 style [ __ ] full hand guards or
that
nice long sight radius but with a
[ __ ] collapsible [ __ ] stock
off of the [ __ ] first generation
classical stock
off of a car 15 it looks [ __ ] great
but it's going to look [ __ ] great
he's just getting the pieces together
and the tools he's going to need to do
stuff
stop prop says youtube doesn't like true
crime at all i don't know i
i subscribe to like a [ __ ] ton of true
crime should i like stephanie harlow i
like brain scratch
um time suck does a lot of true crime he
does some other [ __ ] too but he does a
lot of uh serial killers and [ __ ] like
that
um so you know i i like i watch a lot of
that stuff
yeah okay so uh the next
one was suzanne renee
richardson who was 22 years old
she was last seen october 7th 1988 she
worked as a night clerk
at the casa del mar condominiums
um she was seen about 6 a.m which i
guess was the end of her shift
no one really saw what happened to her
witnesses said that they heard a woman
screaming and they found a shoe that
they think belonged to her in the
parking lot
uh but they have never found her so she
was abducted from her
workplace she was struggling and lost a
shoe
yeah and that's all they've ever found
of her was just one [ __ ] shoe how
[ __ ] creepy is it somebody grabbed
her ass
that's [ __ ] creepy yeah well
obviously mcduck there was another
case unrelated mcduff and his friend
used to [ __ ]
they were [ __ ] real [ __ ] because
it was kind of detailed the tortures
they would do to them
they'd uh do things like pull up into a
they'd see a girl
washing her car at a car wash and they'd
pull up
next to the car wash and it would you
know you know one of the open spaces of
the car wash between the brick walls
which would make her invisible on three
sides
and then they would both run out the
[ __ ] sliding
door on the side of the van and grab the
[ __ ] woman and holler in
beat on her a little bit hand cuff her
[ __ ]
you know restrain her and then drive
drive away that's how easy it was and
they
victimology was is that they would just
choose a woman who was small
yeah that's what they were looking for
if she was small
and cute she couldn't give him a hard
time so i guess i'm safe it's like yeah
try to pick me up [ __ ]
my ass is dense they were looking for
like
five foot and under and around 110.
well yeah because you can just pick them
up and run off and run with them yeah
because they're small
that's what they did yeah and if you've
ever fought a [ __ ] who's bit
much bigger than you i'm five six i've
i've only fought dudes that were bigger
than me
and sometimes more than one and i'm
mostly lost because i was
always against superior opponents i
[ __ ] hate bullies
i never [ __ ] go to [ __ ] fists with
somebody who's smaller than me because
you could
you're gonna be able to reason it out
it's always a big [ __ ] you can't
read
it you know what i mean if the dude can
pick you up
your [ __ ] toast your toast because
you just well you can't do anything at
that point you can't get any left
you can't get any [ __ ] leverage
you're just like scary something out of
a damn cartoon they picked you up and
you just
weigh on and trying to you put some
[ __ ] body weight i mean all you can
do is
so much that they let go of you and then
run like hell that's all you can do
you can't get a good connect it'd be
like
it'd be like floating in a swimming pool
if you guys have never fought imagine
you're floating in a swimming pool
trying to hit the wall real hard
you wouldn't be able to because every
time you hit you you'd move back it's
like that
i know it's scary yeah another true
crime when i like too
so what's her name uh i think her name
is bailey sarian and she does
uh i think it's called murder and makeup
mondays or mystery and makeup monday
something like that
but she is super cute and she um puts on
makeup and she does like different
makeup every time and then talks about a
true crime case at the same time
it's like it doesn't seem like it would
work but it's like i don't know i really
like it it's really there's something
and she's super funny too like i really
like her a lot
um okay so the next one this woman was
last seen sometime in 1991 now for
again the just like in the previous case
of audrey cook
um this was a uh a jane doe or although
they actually called her janet doe
because she was the second one that was
unidentified
now they found her in uh september 8
1991
she was found in the 3000 block of
calder road just like several other
victims
uh at the time that the body was found
they estimated that she was 24 to 34
years old five feet uh
five foot tall to five foot three about
a hundred to 130 pounds uh had been dead
six weeks to several months prior to
being found um
coroner thought she had probably been
strangled to death she had also been
severely beaten around the face and head
2019 uh genealogy
finally identified her as 34 year old
donna
prudhomme who had last been seen
sometime in 1991 not a lot of
information about her
but they finally identified her just
this past year
next to uh another pair of young teenage
girls
lynette bibbs was 14 and tamara fisher
was
15. they were last seen february 1st
1996
they were both at a teen club and they
were there with a friend of theirs a
dude who was older i think he was 22.
um i don't know if they had known him
for a long time
if he was like a friend of theirs or if
he was just some like weird rando that
they had met i don't really know
their uh this 22 year old guy claimed
that he was at the teen club with them
and then he dropped them off
although what's a 22 year old doing
hanging out at a teen club for one thing
that seems a little you was this
96 96 yes too late to be doing that back
in the 70s you could get away with it
yeah 90s it'd be like creeper and they
would be right
so so he said that he had dropped both
the girls off at a motel
on old spanish trail in houston however
two days later their bodies were found
off the side of a dirt road
near cleveland texas they had both been
shot to death
but for whatever reason police suspected
that they had been shot by different
people i don't know because
probably because it was two different
firearms
that doesn't mean it was two different
people but i can see where they're
coming from
but yeah so there was that one
now the next one uh crystal baker
13. this was another kind of high
profile uh case
although um this one was the one that
was solved
uh the one that you were talking about
earlier this this was one of the few
that was actually solved
crystal baker was 13 years old she was
last seen march 5th 1996.
now she had been at her grandmother's
house and apparently they got into an
argument about something i think
because she had skipped school or
something um so
she kind of took off from her
grandparents house
she was seen at a convenience store or a
tire store rather
and she was using the the phone in the
tire store
uh and she called up her family and said
she was sorry and she said she needed a
ride home from the store
now she called the grandmother she
called her parents she called a bunch of
other friends and relatives but
apparently no one could give her a ride
so it's possible she either tried to
walk uh
you know to the house i think it was
five miles or she tried to hitchhike
to there um but regardless of what
happened she didn't
make it two hours after she was last
seen her body was found
she had been raped strangled and dumped
over the i-10 trinity river
bridge yeah it said because the mom
didn't find out until
two weeks later because it happened in
another county
she was yeah her daughter and the
[ __ ] the cops they weren't
communicating with each other i feel
like
that yeah well i feel like i mean this
was 90s
i feel like that might have been i don't
want to blame the cops necessarily
um but i do feel like this kind of whole
interdepartmental
you know we're keeping in purpose you
know this was in this city or this was
in this county
and they're not sharing information and
i think that that might have been a
factor in why a lot of these are not
solved
local law enforcement sees things at
least here in the united states at the
state level
they see things in terms of counties
yeah
and one county may not talk to
surrounding counties
might or they do but it might take them
a while to send that and that
that's what happened is eventually like
a week or so later
that county reported to the other
counties of what what had been happening
in in in that packet of information was
that they had found that body
yeah and that's how the other county
where she went missing found out
it's probably not like that today it's
better now because
internet everything is a lot more
interconnected so
you know people you know there's
nationwide databases and chill it's
still not
great but it's obviously a lot better
than it was back then well there's just
live stuff like facebook and [ __ ] and
youtube will help too because a high
profile case
rises to the top and everybody in the
whole area goes well wait a minute is
that that girl they just found today
here in my county you know i mean that's
that kind of [ __ ] well that's what i
mean that's what's sad it's like they
found the girl's body like two hours
after she was last seen
but because of jurisdictional [ __ ] her
mom
still was hoping she was gonna come home
yeah for like two weeks before they're
like oh
she was found a couple hours by the way
she was dead you know she's been dead
this whole time we found her
like the same day she went missing we
found her a couple hours later kind of
get back to some of the stuff that i was
saying
on the other show is that technology is
advancing so quickly that
a lot of aspects of government federal
and state government is becoming
obsolete there's better faster more
efficient ways of doing this kind of
stuff
and the laws have not caught up with
technology how can
it because technology changes much
faster than laws can
yeah and um
they're gonna have to work out what
[ __ ] government is now
because you know the government
especially at the federal level of what
we have
that the whole concept was from the
1700s
back when you when it took weeks to
[ __ ] ride by horse
you know what i mean to get to the
capitol and all kind of it's not like
that anymore
you don't need a centralized place
everybody can do this from their house
now
so you can govern from your house
there's all kinds of [ __ ] things that
could happen
to make government better um
and it hasn't happened yet but well like
i said everything's
really really slow yeah too slow too
crazy too inefficient
um
it's just and and then the agencies that
are doing it are not
[ __ ] are crazy like who runs the
government do the elected officials run
it or do the intelligence agencies run
it
who runs the [ __ ] federal government
they don't seem to know
there seems to be an argument about that
uh
but let's get back to the [ __ ] show
yeah so
as i said the crystal baker case i'm
gonna go a little bit more into
this later when i talk about suspects
and convictions and everything
um but the crystal baker case was
actually solved
uh the dude that killed her kevin edison
smith who was 45 years old he was
convicted of capital murder in 2012
sentenced to life in prison uh just last
year 2019
uh governor greg abbott signed into law
the crystal gene baker act
which permits the collection of dna from
individuals arrested for certain
felonies prior to conviction
which they hope will clear some cold
cases
uh you know so it was her murder that
spurred the passage of that law
next one was laura smither who was 12
years old last seen april 3rd 1997.
now laura this is so this is sad because
she was only 12. i think she was only
about 20 days from her 13th birthday and
she was super excited
about becoming a teenager she was like
marking every single day and she was
like really jazzed about it
so this little girl she was really
really into ballet dancing
um you know her family was like she was
just like this beautiful she was super
super smart
just this wonderful compassionate little
girl
everybody loved her she lived with her
dad and her stepmother
her biological mother had died of breast
cancer while laura was still a baby
she lived in friendswood texas which at
the time
of her disappearance was actually one of
the top 10 safest
cities in the united states yeah not
after this though
sadly um so basically because she was a
ballet dancer and she wanted to
i guess she wanted to make a career of
that so she wanted to be like the best
she could be like they said she
practiced she would practice all the
time she was super into it
so she decided that she was going to um
you know kind of she was going to do an
exercise regimen so on this particular
morning april 3rd 1997
she told her parents they were making
breakfast they were making pancakes with
chocolate chips in them which was like
her favorite thing
and she's like i'm gonna go for a jog
and they said well
you know we're making breakfast though
and she's like well how long is that
going to take and they said 20 minutes
she'll be back i'll be back in 20
minutes i'm just going to do like a
quick jog
so she went out for a run and did not
come back uh 17 days later
her body was found in a retention pond
in pasadena texas
she was found nude except for tan socks
um her uh parents actually ended up
later there was an interview with them
on uh several of the documentaries
they actually ended up uh establishing
the laura recovery center in 1998
which um again you know helps out
victims of kidnapping and stuff like
that so
you know it's a non-profit organization
now
laura smither even though this one is
not solved solved in the case there
wasn't a conviction
but they're pretty sure they knew who
did this one uh and this was a
[ __ ] named william lewis reese
uh who we will talk about later on he
was actually convicted of a couple of
the other ones
but they think that he probably did this
one too because they found out later
when they were
indicting him for some of the other
crimes that he was
uh driving a bulldozer i guess like in
the same neighborhood where
the smithers lived they were building a
new um
you know a new neighborhood like new
houses and that he this dude was driving
a bulldozer like right
where she would have jogged and zander
and
assassins are [ __ ] with me saying
that i look lit i'm not lit man i'm re
i'm looking at my pad reading what you
guys are saying
i am [ __ ] up though are you really
yeah yeah well my [ __ ] was [ __ ] twice
as strong as yours oh okay
so well yeah i want [ __ ] a bit weaker so
i can kind of i can at least like read
what i remember last time
yeah it's like i don't want to lose
track of my [ __ ] although this one like
i said i'm
you got it pretty it's going i i got
like i'm pretty like organized with this
[ __ ] because i've been like
researching this for like days and days
and so i have all like this one
full of facts too i like this one really
yeah that's good it's yeah so all right
so interestingly
so this so the [ __ ] i just
mentioned william lewis reese
one of the ways they caught him like i
said he hasn't been convicted
of the laura smith or one although
they're pretty sure that he did that one
too
but this is how this [ __ ] ended
up getting caught
so may of 1997
which was um only like a month after
laura smither disappeared there was this
19 year old woman
named sandra sappa i think i'm
pronouncing it right zappa sappo
something like that
so okay she'd been having a rough day
she decided she was gonna leave her
husband she had a couple kids like
little kids
she had packed up all her [ __ ] from the
apartment um
that she shared with her husband she had
taken the kids to their grandparents
house
and she was gonna go she was gonna leave
her husband and she was gonna go stay in
a motel
so she goes to the motel and it was
booked
now she had all her [ __ ] in her van and
she's just kind of like well [ __ ] now
what am i gonna do now
so uh she stops at a convenience store
and you know not a lot of cell phones in
1997.
she stops at a convenience store to pay
phone calls a friend of hers
and is basically like um you know what
am i gonna do can i stay there do you
have some other place i can stay or
whatever
so while she's on the phone she sees
this guy
and hanging around kind of watching her
and she said she even said to the friend
it's like there's this dude who's kind
of hanging around over there by the
dumpster and he's kind of creeping me
out
uh she described him he's a white male
about five nine two hundred pounds
a dirty blonde slicked back hair and a
mustache with bags under his eyes and
kind of
stubble uh he had on jeans a white
t-shirt and a black cowboy hat
driving an oversized white ford or chevy
dually pickup
older model possibly a diesel with an
aluminum toolbox on the bed and a black
stripe along the side
now at some point either while she was
on the phone or after she got off the
phone and was going back to her car the
dude approaches her and says hey
i just noticed that your van has a flat
tire you want me to help you fix it
i guess the tire really was flat
probably he had flattened it
[ __ ]
and um so she was like okay even though
she was kind of creeped out by him
so he uh was like hey why don't you go
get the jack or something like that like
out of my truck
while she did that he came up behind her
put a knife to her throat and forced her
into the truck drove her away in the
truck
uh started beating on her and tried to
rape her
but she jumped out the [ __ ] truck
scraped her [ __ ] [ __ ] all up on the
[ __ ] because truck was moving
she jumped out but wisely as it turned
out
uh because this dude was probably a
serial killer everybody's saying this
show's on point that you're doing great
jenny
well thank you because we're not going
off on foot yeah we're not going
on like i said i don't mind going off on
tangents but sometimes if the tangents
go way too long and then i get like
then then sometimes we'll go off on all
these tangents then i'll get like drunk
and then i'll forget where i was well
that's the problem a lot of the times
it's just so alcohol-fueled that it
never
untangents itself it's just a concept
well i mean after we finish the [ __ ]
after we finish the case we can go off
on some tangents if you want
that's fine
so yeah she jumps out the [ __ ] car
and good for her
now she jumped out the car and then she
looks up and she sees the [ __ ] truck
coming around and he's come back and
[ __ ] get her
so she runs into the [ __ ] highway and
flags the car down
wisely like i said as it turned out so
um
so another car stops it was a 26 year
old woman driving the car named minerva
torres
um and she was a girl get in this
[ __ ] car and she took her to the
hospital
so she ended up having to get a whole
bunch of shoes she'd have broken bones
but she had like a bunch she had like
her head was all [ __ ] up and it needed
stitches and she had like all kind of
abrasions and [ __ ] like that all over
so she was in the hospital for three
days so they can make sure she didn't
have any internal injuries
and then she left the hospital three
days later so
uh the man who tried to kidnap this
woman was later found to be
the [ __ ] that i just mentioned
in relation to the case of laura smither
and whose name will come up again
in a few minutes um william lewis reese
he had an almost identical vehicle
although after it got
out uh that what the truck looked like
he took the aluminum toolbox out and put
like a camper like a camper shell like
on the back and stuff so he'd like be
all sneaky about it
but he had like pretty much the same car
that she described when they brought her
in for a line of like they arrested him
and
brought her in for a lineup and she
immediately was like yeah that's that
dude right there that's that
[ __ ] i recognize him
um so he actually ended up getting
convicted of aggravated kidnapping
uh there were speculations that
prosecutors would also try to get him
for the laura smith or murder because
they thought he was in the
you know the very same street where
laura smith got taken from on the day
that uh
she was killed but they didn't think
they had enough evidence
to convict him of that and they were
afraid that he might get off on a
technicality or something like that say
so we have everything for the aggravated
kidnapping he's been identified
by the victim he was identified by a
clerk at the convenience store
um so we think we have him on that and
they did get him on that so he did go to
prison
um and you know he might have been
involved in a couple of these other ones
too
next uh case jessica kane
17 years old last seen august 17th 1997.
now jessica was actually sadly
ironically was planning on uh she was a
really really good student had gotten
way ahead in
credits in high school and she was
planning on majoring in criminology
in college on the night she vanished
she had actually been in a theater
production she had played marilyn monroe
in a 50s musical revival at a local
local theater her parents had been there
watching her
um after the show ended a bunch of the
other cats were gonna have a cast party
at a restaurant i think it was a benigns
they were all going to go there and hang
out so
she was at the bennigan's with her
friends until about 1 30
a.m um at which time she said you know
i'm really tired i don't really feel
that good
so i'm just going to go ahead and head
home now she had her dad's pickup truck
that she'd been driving
um so she started driving uh toward home
but she never got there
her dad went out looking for her when
she didn't come back home when she
hadn't arrived back home a few hours
later
and uh her father found the truck
abandoned along i-45 south about four
miles from their home
with jessica jessica's purse uh still
inside all her id and everything uh no
signs of a struggle
police noted that a light-colored truck
with a tool box in the back bed
much less like the truck of this [ __ ]
that reese
[ __ ] had been spotted in the
area around the time the disappearance
19 years later jessica's remains were
found in a field
off of east orem road next to hobby
airport uh again
suspected serial killer william lewis
reese the same guy that we talked about
in
conjunction with the last two cases um
actually
told investigators to search the area
where her remains were found so they
presume
that he killed jessica kane as well 2016
he was indicted
for the murders of jessica kane and
laura smith
now that was kind of the last one like i
said you know from the 70s to the 90s
those were i hate to use the word
canonical that's what they usually
always
use for like the jack the ripper murders
but there were a couple of other ones
um that took place kind of outside of
that
that may have been related not really
sure um
there was this one woman like in 2001
named tot harriman now she was older she
was 57.
she was actually driving between league
city and corpus christi
texas looking for a new house and she
was uh last seen driving her 1995
lincoln continental
along highway 35 and disappeared she has
never been found
there was also a woman named sarah
trustee who was 23
she was last seen july 12 2002. she
lived in algoa
texas i guess how you pronounce that she
left
uh in the early evening and was riding
her bike
around the algo baptist church the next
day her bike was found
in the front part of the church and 14
days later her body was found
by fishermen in the texas city dyke she
was found july 27th
now so those i think
um i think there was maybe one more yeah
there's maybe one more
teresa venegas who was 16 she was
actually this is the most recent one she
was last seen
on halloween of 2006 last seen walking
near the green
k subdivision on halloween night three
days later her body was found
strangled raped and with her hair cut
off in a field across from dickinson
high school she was found on november
3rd 2006.
so as i said at least 30 possibly more
because a lot of them
disappeared but a lot of [ __ ] bodies
found in this [ __ ] area
so now let's talk about some of the
suspects now this first guy that we're
going to talk about
you mentioned this because you saw this
on the documentary this dude
probably the worst [ __ ] luck ever
because i don't think even though he's
listening to the suspects
i really don't think this dude had
anything to do with it um
yeah so this is [ __ ] up so back in the
70s
when uh you know when the initial
murders were happening 1972
there's a dude named michael lloyd self
now he worked at a gas station
now he was a convicted sex offender um i
don't think i think it had been a case
of like
he got fixated on this one particular
because he was a little bit
uh slow okay he was a little mentally
slow so i think he had gotten fixated on
this one woman
and i think he'd been kind of like
stalking her peeping or whatever so i
think he was convicted for that
i don't think it was anything i'm not
saying that's good i'm just not saying
it was like super super serious
so now he ended up becoming a suspect in
the murders of rhonda
renee johnson and sharon shaw
mostly because he um
i guess he you know worked at a gas
station in the area i guess he sort of
knew them
but he was real interested in the case
he well the weird thing about it is that
he was really really into true crime
and he was really into cops like he
really liked cops
he liked to hang out with cops and talk
to them about their cases
and it was just like an interest for him
um
so there wasn't a lot of crime in the
area
so when these two girls got murdered it
was kind of a big deal
so he sort of wanted to talk to
everybody about it but the more he
talked to everybody about it people
started getting suspicious like maybe he
had done it
and as i said he was in the area and he
did kind of know them at least
at least they were like acquaintances
because they lived in the same area
now what ended up happening is they
bring in michael self
for questioning now
no one's entirely sure what happened in
that interrogation room i have some
suspicions
but after several hours of the
interrogation
he confessed to the murders although i
will note that his first
confession was not
real accurate to the facts of the crimes
i want to announce that we're at 81.
nice yeah which is pretty good so
hernandez was right i didn't realize
that we uh
actually got up to sometimes 80 viewers
this is
this is near a record though yeah for
this little chef
that's cool i would love imagine if we
had like 300 on there
man there are some shows that i watch
man like they're [ __ ]
bumping like 4 000 people [ __ ] live
i would love to have a show that big but
i just think youtube's against us
i don't think it's that i just i think
shows that it get i don't know it's like
i
i just kind of feel like a lot of shows
that get real popular are ones that are
just kind of like
hey let's [ __ ] on everything and insult
people and do that kind of [ __ ] people
people like watching negatives no
they're just having fun they're having
fun but it does have a negative element
sometimes but and i don't like watching
shows like that
but you know i guess a lot of people do
it just depends on what it's it's
what the market the market loves that
kind of well that's what i'm saying i
don't like that kind of [ __ ] that that
kind of [ __ ] annoys me
but a lot of people do we try to keep
the show [ __ ] balanced for everybody
but
if we were to like you know go hardcore
one side or the other and probably pick
up some but that's not the nature of
this show but
well i wouldn't really enjoy it either i
mean i just feel like it would because
[ __ ] like that annoys me like
we do have fun though yeah some of the
[ __ ] that annoys you that have fun and
all of a sudden
we'll get super chats it is funny
do you know where the money really comes
in jenny and i'm is when i when i pick
them boobs up
when i lift those boobs next thing you
know like in 30 40 dollars comes
and they're so heavy they're [ __ ]
heavy heavy
have a video one of these days of just
me way in a boob
we're gonna like on a digital scale
it's gonna be a blue drop like that
we're gonna put that
yeah even the girls will pay
that's going to be a really i'm just
trying to like because we have that
digital scale that's like really close
to the ground i'm like man i'm really
going to have to lay in an awkward
position
you guys know that you guys know the
deal with this team here we got real
[ __ ]
miss analytical she's gonna [ __ ] do
all the research and
i'm more like [ __ ] i feel like i'm
[ __ ]
pt barnum i'm more of the [ __ ]
salesman
but i think that's probably why it works
that's why a lot of people seem to like
it because
we have like we're coming out from like
two different totally different styles
because we have two completely kind of
yeah i don't know we have two really
different personalities but we have like
some so a lot of similarities too yeah
we've been partners in crime for [ __ ]
more than 10
10 years so yeah and it started in night
clubs
yeah so yeah we're [ __ ]
good before we were even [ __ ] a
couple we were good friends and we were
[ __ ] yeah because i think we were
hanging out for like a year and a half
before we yeah like before you
got together i was hanging out with you
when you were married yeah you were
that's why that dude thought i stole you
i didn't steal you
he just lost i just left you know yeah
because then we were single for about
another 18 months and
we were [ __ ] hooking up with other
people at the nightclub
you know yep but you know that was my
[ __ ] days
[ __ ] everybody's days
[Laughter]
when you get down to it all you
[ __ ] are [ __ ]
and i can prove it okay i can prove it
if i were to know the details i could
point it out it says
look you're a hoe here you're a [ __ ]
here and you're a [ __ ] right there
you're a [ __ ] a [ __ ] and a hoe
see i can do it to anybody sure anybody
can do that to anybody
so it's it's a move point it's not true
it's not true well like i said it's just
when you call somebody a [ __ ] it just it
seems like you're
trying to shame this shallow yeah yeah
you can't
[Laughter]
but yeah so this allegedly
poor [ __ ] michael self so
so i said so they got him to sign a
confession
but the first confession there was a lot
of details
like he said [ __ ] like i picked up one
of the girls from their house
which they knew wasn't true because both
the girls were like out on the street
um he said yeah i hit him both in the
head with a coke bottle and knocked him
out
um not true because there was no head
trauma at all
um so there was like a lot of details
that was in the first confession that
were obviously you know didn't line up
with the facts of the case
but weirdly what ended up happening was
that
later he retracted his confession
because he said look the cops
essentially tortured him into i mean
they beat the [ __ ] out of him
allegedly this is what michael self said
um and he said one of the cops
put one round in the chamber of his uh
service revolver spun it and then put it
to his head and pulled the trigger
um and basically threatened hey sign the
confession or i'll blow your head off
essentially
um so michael self was scared
uh as you would because like i said he
wasn't you know he wasn't all there
um he was a little slow so he was
terrified
uh and he's like okay fine i'll sign
whatever you want now the second
confession
came out and uh interestingly even
though the first one was kind of wildly
all over the place and had a lot of
details that didn't line up with the
crimes
second one sounded just like the crimes
and they got him to sign that one too
because like i said i'm pretty sure they
were threatened to like
beat the [ __ ] out of him and shoot him
in the face so he was like whatever
i'll uh you know i'll i'll [ __ ] sign
anything
okay i'm gonna let her out hold on all
right i gotta send you a message and i'm
gonna let go you be good pookie don't
you go anyplace
but yeah he said that the cops like you
know tried to suffocate him with a
plastic bag they were like burning them
cigarettes all kind of [ __ ]
and that the police chief had beat him
up so
sadly the confession
even though there was not a shred of
physical evidence
uh tying this guy to the murder to this
double murder
um the confession was enough that he got
convicted and he got life
in prison now
three years after this in 1976
don morris who was the police chief and
the deputy tommy deal who were two of
the guys that he had accused of beating
the [ __ ] out of him like essentially
beating a confession and torturing a
confession out of him
those two guys they got arrested and
convicted
they were [ __ ] not only were they
torturing
and uh you know beating up on other
suspects like to get them to confess
they were also [ __ ] bank robbers they
had robbed a whole bunch of banks
while this was going on while he was the
police chief while he was a deputy
they were going to another small town
they were robbing banks like all of its
[ __ ] place right
and they were also beating up other
suspects and [ __ ] like that okay so they
got convicted of that
but which you would think that when that
[ __ ] came out people be like hey maybe
we should look into that michael self
guy
you know maybe he's innocent and we
should let him out
um they did kind of look into that like
some appeals and [ __ ]
but didn't work um
he had a bunch of appeals and basically
what the appeal said it's about
you know i'm not a lawyer um but the
legalese type of [ __ ]
the gist of it was that well
back in the day you had the chance to
say that your confession was coerced
which he did but they're like well you
didn't prove it back then
so we can't overturn the jury's decision
so you got to stay in jail so all his
appeals were used up
and he was in he stayed in [ __ ] jail
and he died
in prison in 2000 still in jail
even though 99 sure he didn't do that
[ __ ]
that he just got beat into a confession
and then he ended up in jail and he died
in there so you know
special um so yeah that was kind of like
a [ __ ] sad story
now let's talk about this [ __ ]
edward harold bell
now a lot of investigators uh think this
dude is like the prime suspect at least
for
the 70s era murders this dude
crazy this dude is so [ __ ] crazy
so this guy um he was a suspect in the
1970s so he was like on the
investigator's radar right
now his big thing he was kind of an
exhibitionist
uh he'd been arrested about a dozen
times
on charges of showing his genitals to
children he was real
fond of finding some kids hanging out
somewhere
pulling up in his car getting out of his
car with no pants on
and jerking it in front of children damn
he was super super into that
um so yeah he lived around the time that
the murders were going on he did live in
galveston and he
actually matter of fact uh he either
owned a surf shop there or
was part owner of like a surf shop or a
dive shop or something like that
he actually did know two of the victims
debbie ackerman and maria johnson who
had disappeared at the same time they
came in his store all the time
um and he later wrote a letter to
galveston authorities claiming
responsibility for those two murders in
particular
and he got details about the crime right
such as the caliber of the gun that have
been used
357 magnum and the position of the
gunshot wounds like they said that um
it looked like one of the girls had been
shot from above and he
said in the letter yeah i stood up on
the bridge and shot him up there so you
know
so his [ __ ] checked out so
mid-1970s he actually um
bought a plot of land in dickinson texas
and ended up living near the place where
two of the other victims brooks
braceball and georgia gear who also
disappeared at the same time uh were
last seen alive
1978 this is and now this is interesting
1978 um bell was doing his thing where
he was jerking it on the street in front
of much kids because that was
what he did as you as you do just get
out of the car no pants on
start jerking it from little children um
so he started doing that
i think it was teenage girls this time
not that that makes it better
so he was doing that and a a former
marine
named larry dickens who was 26 years old
came out his house i think and was like
uh hey
knock that [ __ ] off as you would
hopefully
um and
ed bell ended up shooting
this dude i mean he he essentially like
executed him
he shot him i think four times in the
chest
and then larry was still alive and he
was still kicking and like ed
basically in the [ __ ] driveway in the
middle of the day
kind of sits on the dude's body and just
like shoots him in the [ __ ] head
so he kills him like executes him in his
own [ __ ] driveway
now interestingly this is a fun fact um
when this case was featured on unsolved
mysteries back in the 90s
i want to say well it was robert stack
was still alive
they covered this on unsolved mysteries
and
the person playing uh
larry dickens the dude that got killed
was none other than matthew mcconaughey
this was his first acting role i think
was on unsolved mysteries playing this
dude that got killed by ed bell
in the whole texas killing fields thing
so at this point
uh after edward killed this dude
he uh fled texas and actually got out of
the united states
um and actually the police did not find
him for almost
20 years more than 20 years afterwards
1994 he gets arrested in panama and he
got extradited back to the u.s
and then he got convicted of dickens
murder and he got a 70-year sentence for
that
now 1998 he starts writing all these
weird [ __ ] letters
to um the harris county attorney
and he confessed that he had killed five
girls in 1971
and six more between 1974 and 1977.
now these girls he called these murders
the 11 who went to heaven
and these consisted of and the details
that he gave
very very similar to the 11
victims that i talked about other than
allison craven who may have been
that might have been another uh murderer
but so he's looking pretty good for that
kind of [ __ ] he did confess
to it he knew some details about the
[ __ ] he didn't know
he didn't remember a lot of their names
um but he
did remember yeah i killed debbie
ackerman and maria johnson because like
i said he knew them because they'd come
into his
surf shop or his dive shop or whatever
um he was pretty sure he had killed
colin wilson
he was pretty sure he had killed
kimberly pitchford he remembered her
last name
um and he remembered he killed two other
ones but he couldn't remember their
names
but he said oh i abducted him from
webster in august 1971.
uh that would have been renee johnson
and sharon shaw
so a lot of [ __ ] he said in the letters
like lined up with what the crimes were
now despite that though they didn't have
a lot of physical evidence tying him to
the crimes
other than his confession and also like
i said
he seemed pretty crazy because
you guys are gonna love this the reason
that he gave
for all the jerking in front of kids all
the murdering
all the [ __ ] that he was doing was
because i'm not sure
if i can completely do justice to this
because i'm not
insane but his excuse
was that there was a
secret government program
and it was mind controlling him he
called it the program that's just what
he called it
and he said that it was like i think he
said it was a seven step program
and the government was trying to see if
they could turn a good person
like him presumably into an evil person
the first step of the program if i
remember correctly was
making you gay um there was also what
else was in there there was
there were some other steps in there
about making you use your penis to do
things you don't want to do
um i think the last step was making you
a jesus freak
so essentially he was saying that
government mind control
made him kill people and jerk off in
front of
children that was his excuse did it make
him gay
no well he said they were trying to make
him gay right yeah well that was
supposedly the first step in the program
i think it was the
so so he that was the first step he went
ahead and he tipped his [ __ ] hand
right there he showed us his cards
this all started with him looking at men
thinking maybe i should maybe i should
do that okay
then he blamed it on somebody else okay
this is like some [ __ ] out of [ __ ]
dr strangelove where you launch the
nuclear weapons because you can't get a
heart on
remember that that's yeah that's
essentially what it is that's what he's
talking about i hate to say it but it's
like in a lot of these serial killer
cases
it really is that simple it's just it's
a big thing it's a big thing
i can't my dick can't get hard so
they're trying to kill a [ __ ] so
it's time to kill somebody or they come
up with some elaborate framework that is
obviously
just making up for purely of essence
lack of yes
of decoration fluoridation in the water
has made me not get it up so i'm gonna
launch the nuclear missiles
yeah yeah that's dude logic dude logic
that's what that is that was a great
move
it really was i need to watch that again
actually um but yeah so this
crazy ass mother i mean okay how crazy
could he be though because
he ran a bunch of businesses
successfully as far as i know
um after he killed people he did manage
to like get the [ __ ] out of the country
and evade the authorities for more than
20 years
so he can't have been that crazy you
know what i'm saying
i don't know if he was just using that i
mean yes
it does sound like schizophrenia uh that
kind of [ __ ] like oh the government's
mind controlling me and making me
jerk off in front of children um but
on the other hand was he just using that
as an excuse
to get away with [ __ ] i don't really
know um
happily this [ __ ] died in 2019.
not so happily they never did have
enough physical evidence to
convict him of any of the murders
although i think most investigators are
pretty sure
um that he at least did some of the
murders from the 70s if not all 11 of
them
um just he knew a lot of details about a
lot of the crimes that
led them to believe that probably he had
something to do with it
so now let's talk about this
[ __ ] that we mentioned before
william lewis reese so in may of 1997
reese was arrested for kidnapping and
attempted murder of 19 year old
sandra sipa which i mentioned before she
got away from him
now the following year he got found
guilty of that and he was convicted he
got 60 years
in prison meant now 2015 because they
also did some dna
matching he met his dna matched to
another murder
uh which is like not even related to the
texas uh killing fields murders this was
another
woman a 19 year old named tiffany
johnson and she was actually found
murdered in oklahoma in 1997.
so dna like linked him to that one
and then uh once they confronted him
with that information
he also came forward and said that he
had also killed jessica kane
uh the girl the 17 year old that had
disappeared they you know her
they found her car abandoned on the side
of the road uh he said he killed her too
and he also killed another girl named
kelly cox somewhere else
uh and he actually apparently like led
uh the cops to
where they were buried so that that
seems a pretty good
good indicator of guilt there uh as i
said earlier he's also suspected in uh
the kidnapping and killing of 12 year
old laura smither
but they didn't have enough physical
evidence time although like i said he
was driving a bulldozer
along that exact same street on that
exact same day when she disappeared
uh and he's killed a bunch of other
people so it seems pretty obvious that
he did that as well
so uh the next guy we're gonna talk
about clyde edwin hedrick
uh this guy so march of 2014
this dude got sentenced to 20 years in
prison uh for involuntary manslaughter
for the 1984 beating death of 29 year
old real estate office receptionist
ellen ray
beason now hedrick was the person last
seen with uh
beeson they had been out at a nightclub
in league city texas it was called the
texas moon
uh interestingly this nightclub was uh
the same one that heaty fay uh and he
fire rather um
one of the other victims of the texas
killing fields she went to this
nightclub as well so henrik was seen
with
um with uh ellen beason
on this particular night in july of 1984
he
initially told investigators that she
that he had left the club with her and
that she had decided to go swimming
and that she had drowned and that he had
hidden her body
but then later when they re-examined the
body they found that she'd actually been
beaten to death and they determined that
probably he had killed her and then just
dumped her along a dirt road in
galveston
so clyde hedrick has also been is also
suspected
in the murders of hedify who like i said
uh went to that same nightclub
uh maybe laura miller uh maybe michelle
garvey and possibly
audrey cook who was the first jane doe
they actually
wanted to present evidence of hedrick
linking him to the murders of
uh hedify and laura miller but the link
was never made miller's father
tim uh who like i said founded echo
search suspected
hedrick murdered his daughter but this
was after
he got over this whole robert abel thing
because let's talk about
these two guys robert abel and mark
stallings
now these two dudes okay so robert abel
was he worked for nasa he was a rocket
scientist
is what he was um brilliant a little
weird
but you know a lot of people that are
that intelligent are a little weird
now he initially came on the police's
radar for some of these crimes because
he um owned a piece of land like right
adjacent to the calder or oil field
where like a bunch of the bodies
had been found
and also the fbi had drawn up a profile
of the killer particularly these uh the
ones that occurred in the 80s
and he pretty much fit that profile to a
t uh one of the
um one of the aspects that they were
talking about was uh cruelty to animals
and
several like two of his ex-wives said
that he was very very cruel to his
horses he had like a horse farm he ran a
business it was essentially like a
horseback riding
ranch or something so like people would
come and pay like to ride horses
so he had that and his ex-wives said
that he would beat his horses with an
iron
bar um and when they died he would just
kind of like leave him out in the field
like for the vultures to eat them and
like that he was real weird like that
um so so there was that whole thing like
so like i said he
he fit a lot of the things that the fbi
profile was very meticulous he was very
organized
he had a piece of land right next to
where a lot of the bodies were found
like the you know the land where a lot
of the bodies were found so they thought
he was a little bit suspicious
now tim miller who was laura's father
one of the victims
um as i said he founded equisearch later
on for a time
he was absolutely convinced that robert
abel
was a serial killer um and that he had
particularly killed laura miller and
probably uh
you know possibly several other victims
as well he was so convinced of this
that he essentially harassed the guy
day and night he would like turn up at
his house he had the cops come and
search the property they didn't find
anything
um he would like [ __ ] i don't know he
just like hung out outside his house he
like put [ __ ] [ __ ] in his mailbox
stuff like that
or put letters in his mouth like he was
actual [ __ ] in his mailbox that i know
of
um and at one point too i think he
actually went to his house to talk to
him and the guy said something sideways
and tim miller apparently put a gun in
his face and was gonna shoot him
now what enough happening with that was
that
as convinced as he was finally after a
time
tim miller became convinced he's like
man i just got so focused on this one
guy
that i lost my head like he kind of felt
like after he pulled the gun in the
dude's face he was just kind of like
whoa man i just like went where the [ __ ]
out there
and then when he looked into it because
they couldn't really find any physical
evidence tying him to it and he's like
and i'm essentially like ruining this
dude's life because i'm just like
harassing him i'm ruining his reputation
so because the guy lost his job and all
this other kind of [ __ ] so
the two men reconciled i guess and
robert abel said you know that he
forgave him and [ __ ] however
i believe it was in 2005 robert abel
drove his little atv onto a uh
railroad track and let a train hit him
um was it suicide
probably i think it was ruled an
accident but it wasn't really ruled a
suicide because he didn't live a note or
nothing
but some people that knew him said well
he had just been harassed so much and
like got tied with these murders
that he couldn't really get a job
anymore he could like his whole life was
ruined
so he just decided he was going to take
himself out
but the weird thing though is that there
was this dude who worked for robert abel
named mark stallings
now mark stallings who worked on this
ranch
was actually a convicted kidnapper which
we'll get to get into in a minute
now he confessed to killing a girl in
1991 this was in 2013
and uh later dumped her body in the
fields now this
girl this woman that he later confessed
to killing
they think might have been donna perdome
who was initially known as janet doe one
of the texas killing fields
crime so this guy confessed to killing
her in 2013.
now he said i don't know if this is true
or not he said that donna
was a sex worker who told him that
she would do him for ten dollars because
she needed ten dollars to buy crack
like i said i don't know if that's true
or not because this dude
got some issues with women uh does not
like prostitutes
and uh probably killed two or three
other prostitutes
so i don't really know if you want to
believe anything he says but he did uh
confess to killing who they later think
was donna pruden
now at the time of the murder mark
stallings was
living and working in league city texas
um and was kind of in the area where
some of the girls uh went missing uh and
were murdered
he also got charged with a burglary in
1991.
uh 1996 he went to prison for shooting
an old man through a window
which seems not very sporting
the aggravated kidnapping charge which
he was convicted of
in 2013 that actually stemmed from him
being in jail for another thing
and then he took a guard hostage with a
gun that someone had smuggled in for him
so then he got [ __ ] added on for
aggravated kidnapping
now a lot of the [ __ ] that he says kind
of lines up with some of the cases so he
might have been responsible for some of
them now like i said
i don't know how much stock to put in
what he says
he says he was working at robert abel's
ranch
and he says when he first started
working there him and robert abel were
like simpatico man because it's like
we both had a dark side they both kind
of had really shitty views of
women um that basically you just use
them and beat them
beat the [ __ ] out of them if you wanted
to particularly prostitutes to you know
they hated prostitutes or at least he
did and said that robert abel did too
and it's like yeah we just go out and
get prostitutes and then we just like
rape him to kill him
because you're a prostitute so we can
just do whatever we want to i mean he
basically said that outright
um he said that robert abel had told him
that robert abel had killed a prostitute
i don't know if that's true or not
um mark stalling said that he had killed
two prostitutes and i think that he was
actually either indicted or convicted of
that
he kind of went and picked them up and
then he killed him and he said that he
buried some of the ranch
and like i said he said that robert abel
said that he'd kill the prostitute and
bear the ranch but when they
searched the ranch because like i said
tim miller was all up in there saying
you know robert abel's the serial killer
is you gotta go search his land and the
police did search all his lamp but they
didn't find anything
so i don't know even though mark
stallings
is obviously a shitty dude and did some
[ __ ] and he's confessed to some murders
i don't really know how much
stock you can put in some of the [ __ ]
that he said about robert abel or about
some of the murders that were committed
because some of the prostitutes they
said the kids like they didn't know
their real names
um they didn't really have any crimes
like one of the girls he said her
street name was champagne he didn't know
what her real name was and it's like
so i don't know that's a perfect hooker
name when you think about it it's kind
of
it's kind of the quintessential champion
i feel like
um you know yeah that's a good name
that's what i was i'm ready for business
[Laughter]
yeah he's going to go find the process
well it's really funny because i was
watching something the other day i don't
remember what it was but somebody
happened to mention offhand before i'd
even started researching this kate this
this dude and somebody mentioned offhand
that
that was like the perfect hooker name or
that was kind of the quintessential
hooker name was champagne
and then i started reading about this
guy and he's like oh my god i wonder if
he got
that's really weird it was like a weird
like synchronicity i don't know i never
heard of a hooker named chip i don't
know a lot of hookers i'm just saying
that
i never heard of one named champagne but
apparently that's a really common
that's a that's a really common sex
worker alias apparently who knew i don't
i don't know
but so i don't know like i said for a
long time tim miller seemed really
convinced that
robert abel was maybe the killer but
then later he kind of reconsidered he
went
he leaned more toward clyde hedrick
um but mark stallings the dude that
worked for robert abel for a time
he for sure seemed like a scumbag um
whether he and robert abel were working
together
hey we're going to go out and pick up
girls and kill him and bury him on the
ranch
i don't know um you know i did as far as
i know i think that robert
you know robert abel is dead now
obviously because he got himself hit by
train
but so we can't ask him i don't know if
he was guilty or not they didn't find
anything
when they searched his uh searched his
ranch so what do i know
now um i mentioned this earlier but
we'll go a little bit into
a little more into it now so this was
the crystal gene
baker case she was uh 13. now this
guy was actually convicted so april of
2012
uh which was 16 years after crystal
baker's uh
body was found kevin edison smith
got arrested and he was eventually
convicted of murdering her
now this guy this is kind of interesting
because
he had been in he had been arrested on
drug charges in 2009 now he didn't have
a
um a long rap sheet it was just minor
[ __ ] it was just kind of like you know
dui
drug charges and nothing violent nothing
like that i think he'd kind of like
tried to get away from a cop or
something like when they
pulled him over it wasn't anything that
would imply that he was like a serial
killer
um but i don't know it could be
so what ends up happening so he gets
arrested for a drug charge in louisiana
now around the same time as that
happened somebody thought to take the
dress that crystal gene baker had been
wearing when her body was found and test
the dna
because as i said you know now dna was
much better so they tested it
and they found um
kevin smith's dna on her dress
so they bring smith in
and at first he denies it like i don't
know how how that happened
why would my why would my dna be on her
dress blah blah blah but after a while
he finally fessed up to
it now this was his story he said
that he had been drinking with his
friends that day it's the middle of the
day
i'm not judging so he'd been drinking
with his friends like he usually did
he's like oh yeah something we usually
did was we usually would like sit around
and we'd drink a lot and then we'd go
get a hooker so he said that he was like
super drunk
that he got in his car and that he was
driving along
and that he saw crystal gene baker who
was [ __ ] 13
he saw her walking down the road like to
wherever she was going
he said he thought she was a prostitute
and trying to get her to get in the car
now she
was walking she was trying to walk to
her friend's house which like i said was
like five miles away
so i guess like he said yeah i'll give
you a ride
and maybe she got in i'm not really sure
but apparently she gets in the car and
then he starts
harassing her like hey you how much do
you charge and
i'm and he pulls over like behind a gas
station is like wanting a [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
she's like no i just want to ride i
thought you were just giving me a ride
what the [ __ ]
and she starts fighting him as you would
he gets mad
and then strangles her with a belt he
said
that he didn't intend to kill her but
he just got mad because he was drunk and
he thought she was a hooker and he was
upset because
he was because she wasn't giving it up
she was [ __ ] 13
and he just saw her walking on the side
of the road thought she's a prostitute
yeah she just needed a red he said he
didn't mean to kill her
um jury didn't buy it one thing
one thing that he said this is one quote
that he had this pissed me off a lot
i was just playing and she went berserk
he was just playing
he was just trying to force himself on
her sexually just playing yeah
and she just went crazy why would she
fight i don't know i had to kill her
what the [ __ ] man what the [ __ ] i saw
his little
i saw his testimony though he was lying
that's not what yeah no [ __ ] that's not
what really happened yeah the jury
didn't buy it either no
he saw her and targeted her and he's
like she's weak enough i can take her
and and the dude that you're talking
about is not a specimen of a man
he's a [ __ ] it's just like i said
before it's always these [ __ ] not
even a beta it's like a [ __ ] omega
male you know what i mean bottom rung
of uh you know what i mean he's a bottom
rung type male
small bad shape not a good looking face
you can tell there's nothing to him in
terms of [ __ ]
you know social ability it's just a
bottom feeder
bottom feeder yeah that's all it is and
i kind of suspect
the way that he sort of deflected and
the way the situation went down
i it would not shock me if he um
was if they found out that he killed
other people yeah i do not think that
that was the first time that that had
happened
and you know i don't don't think i'm
being sizes
about the small comment i'm five six i'm
not a big guy
it's just that some dudes
it's a is a combination of a lot of
features that are unpopular
i mean i'm a short guy it never
[ __ ] was an obstacle for me i guess
it's just because
how i played the hand i was dealt
did you see me as some short guy when
you first saw me
you know what it it never occurred to me
that you were
sure sure yeah you said something about
it like years ago i've never laid out
of myself i never thought of you like
that i never thought of myself as like
that either i don't know you don't
say particularly i had had kind of a
long
history of competence where i was doing
[ __ ] and getting [ __ ] done so i never
saw myself as ineffectual
you know what i mean yeah some guys do
though
and it starts to compound well they get
so insecure about it and they
and sometimes it's like all they can
think about and they just have to like
overcompensate yeah they go way off in
the other direction
yeah well i could say well i was over
compensating before i knew i was [ __ ]
short though that's not the deal
this this guy's not overcompensating he
went down a [ __ ] bad
path that's not overcompensation you
can't
characterize it that way yeah you know
what i mean
[ __ ] i was overcompensating at five
i was always trying to [ __ ] grow
you know what i mean and to and to get
bigger in scope
you know what i mean i'm looking at my
babysitter going man i could take that
she looked just like princess leia i
love that one
and i'm the human teddy bear all these
girls with the [ __ ]
little young teenage girls at the damn
slumber party
that's right level up on it baby jammies
and [ __ ] you know what i mean
so did you have footy pajamas footy
jammies and [ __ ]
and they're [ __ ] burning common
little footy pajamas looking like damien
from that one yeah look just like damien
from the home
actually [ __ ] you know what i mean
they're burning incense and listening to
the [ __ ]
led zeppelin and i'm like yeah that's
right baby
and you know to me these 12 13 14 year
old girls they were [ __ ]
you know what i mean goddesses yeah i
mean so
it's just i don't know man i can't i
can't explain it it's just that some
dudes are just destined to be [ __ ]
losers and i think it's because they
play in to the loser game or
they don't know how to expand on
themselves you know what i mean they
don't know how to improve what they have
well i mean we've brought this up many
times on the show it's like you know
to a large extent sometimes i mean you
can fix some things obviously but some
things you're just kind of like stuck
with
um you know your height is one of those
things that's kind of a hard thing to
fix
you can work with anything though but
and that's what i was just going to say
it's like anything you're kind of stuck
with or anything you get
is you can yeah you can do [ __ ] with
that just
[ __ ] work it i've seen dudes that i
would think that
but if you look at them just physically
that they're that the guy would be
unsuccessful just with [ __ ] beautiful
[ __ ] women and
lots of friends and lots of success you
know what i mean but you look at the guy
you think it might
wouldn't be anything to him until you
talk to him the motherfucker's just
entertaining his [ __ ] you know what i'm
talking about it's like a good character
that's what i'm saying
like okay what was his name was named
williams the guy from [ __ ] that
that um little bitty short guy with a
funny haircut
was nothing special he was in phantom of
the paradise
paul williams paul williams that's what
i was going to say
if you were to look at paul williams
you'd think that you think that that
dude would be a loser
no that dude had a [ __ ] ton of money and
in his day in the 70s i don't know how
long he lived
okay i don't know if that was back in
the day where dudes at od
all the time paul williams
was known for always being surrounded by
beautiful [ __ ] women
celebrity women liked him you know
it was paul williams yeah i know but he
had built a legend around himself he
didn't start off as the paul williams
that you saw
it was something that he had earned well
he was talented and he had a good
personality
and he could talk a good game like you
know like he said he was entertaining
people wanted to be around him
yeah you just have to be a person that
people want to be around yeah really i
mean that's
and if you have the intelligence you
realize that pretty much anybody with a
certain amount of intellect can become
you don't even need to be that
intelligent at least average
intelligence
you can you can work with what you have
yeah
that's my message to you [ __ ]
just don't yeah just don't try not to
like get
it you know all in nerd and like [ __ ]
self-pity
don't go negative try not to do that
it's it that's like a i understand that
but it's that's like a bad even i can go
negative jenny you go man you get
negative yeah yeah yeah you got it
i get like that too sometimes everyone
does it's human
you know [ __ ] having my blood work
done and looking at my [ __ ] t levels
i said oh of course i'm so negative yeah
[ __ ] you know what i mean there's
there's there's
biology's involved too yeah you know
what i mean
oh yeah biochemistry so because i'm
talking to people in the chat
in the chat as well because it's harder
for some people like if you're
if your brain chemicals are like all
[ __ ] awry then obviously it's going
to be much harder yeah some people you
know it's easy for
some people to just say oh cheer up or
something like that if you if you're
yeah
it's all messed up there are some people
that [ __ ] are taking you know what i
mean
that need antidepressants in my case i
[ __ ] just
did the [ __ ] blood test and said [ __ ]
my [ __ ] testosterone is [ __ ]
super super [ __ ] low and i know it
was that low i'd gone on at 40
you know and i know what that was that
started and jenny jenny and i tracked it
back
that was because my dad was dying
because depression
when you came back because he you were
gone for two weeks yeah when you came
back from
mississippi from seeing your dad yeah i
was different he didn't die he's still
alive
still alive but you said that i mean
that affected you a lot
yeah i i noticed that you changed a lot
yeah i was watching i got very negative
yeah and i felt like well [ __ ] the hand
of death is after me too
because you saw it happening to your dad
i was like so different then
and uh that will [ __ ]
cause men to [ __ ] stop testosterone
product production
and and you will [ __ ] get even more
depressed
um and this is i should have [ __ ]
listened because all my va [ __ ]
a lot of these guys are coming back out
of combat army rangers [ __ ] sf guys
they get out of service [ __ ] 20 years
of service at [ __ ] 26 27
28 years old and their [ __ ]
testosterone is like
130 that's [ __ ] dead and they put
them on [ __ ] trt and all of a sudden
they're
they feel a lot better and then they
don't
get depressed and [ __ ] you know what i
mean and and uh they don't [ __ ]
kill themselves like they did back in
the vietnam era it's because they know
about that [ __ ] now
yeah you know success breeds success
failure breeds more failure yeah you
really get into kind of a spiral it's
not
but you really can't get like you know
caught up in one particular
way of thinking [ __ ] when you're
living the [ __ ]
high life high energy life as a young
man you're
you're way up here and then you leave
service and all that shit's gone and you
just fall
the [ __ ] crash and that's why i was
just talking to somebody in there about
[ __ ] elvis
that's what happened to elvis elvis
lived way up here
he was living on a high and then all of
a sudden you notice at 35
he started to [ __ ] fall apart and
that was because around that time he
kind of went into semi-retirement he
went from being real famous
to not being you know he was still
famous but he wasn't on stage all the
time
and depression got him yeah it wasn't
like a-list anymore well i think that's
kind of that's bad because sometimes
when you're real young and you have all
of this adulation and
accolades and something like thrown your
way yeah um
you know and then you have all of that
and then it's gone
yeah i feel like that might almost be
worse than never
never having it right because he would
because you know what it's like
you know what it's like to be adored
yeah and to be famous and rich and
everything like that and then when
when it goes down just a little bit then
all of a sudden it's the end of the
world yeah
and that's what elvis was coming down
off a huge [ __ ] high
and he went into a [ __ ] depression
spiral
and started taking drugs that he never
recovered from
and they didn't know back then why'd he
gain all that weight why did he get all
that depression why'd he do that why did
he kill himself with drugs today
at 35 they had to [ __ ] tested his
blood and said dude you need tr
they have boosted him they've t-boosted
him he'd lost a bunch of weight felt a
lot better he'd been out there [ __ ]
back on top yeah he'd have done well
yeah
look at look at stallone we were talking
about stallone too
as old as that [ __ ] is he's way up
here he's gonna live that way until he
dies
you know well and another thing too is
you just have to get and
you know i have to tell myself this like
pretty much every day too but you just
have to kind of
as shitty as some things that happen are
you really just kind of have to roll
with the punches and be
just kind of like well you know is this
really as bad as i think it is or it's
like you know
it'll pass and it's like you just kind
of have to well women keep on going
there are biological differences between
men and women men and women are built
differently
men women their hormones
get affected at menopause men it starts
it can affect in their 30s around 35
and it's that's when depression and
negativity can kick in
because evolution did not really design
us to live very long not men
yeah you just impregnate some people and
then you die [ __ ] off yeah and it's not
even
that's not even a human that's other
other males and other species do the
same thing too they don't live long
they're like drones
okay they fight they [ __ ] and then they
die that's it
and because we're humans we're living a
lot longer than we should
and i'm saying this because guys in the
[ __ ] comment section were asking me
questions about trt and [ __ ]
when you get around 40 get your blood
[ __ ] serum levels tested
check your test really they should be
doing that [ __ ] for free men's health
it's just like going on the pill
like a woman going on the pill it's just
they're going to tweak your hormones
and take you back to what you were when
when you were in an earlier state
like in your 20s or 30s you'll feel a
lot better
i if knowing what i know now at 51 i
should have gone on that [ __ ] at 40.
even though i was doing good at 40. yeah
but um
knowing what i know now i should have
been bumped up at 40.
it'll avoid it avoid so much damage
cardiovascular damage and all kinds of
other stuff i mean
the thing like and sophie pointed this
out too it's like women are kind of used
to
their hormones being like [ __ ] all
over the place yeah
we got like that [ __ ] you know we got
the monthly [ __ ]
um and that kind of makes you
i didn't really get crazy around that
time but i was like horrible horrible
horrible
pain yeah men men and
they'll all attest right there in the
comment section men are used to being
the same
always and as soon as you feel like
you're not on the game anymore
you tend to crumple and die in geologic
terms yeah because from the geological
point of view we don't live long anyway
uh just that no [ __ ] go out there get
your blood [ __ ] levels tested see
see how much test is going on there and
the doctors at the clinics will know
you want to go to testosterone clinic or
what they call it hormone thera hormone
replacement clinic clinic if you're in a
good state they'll have them
it doesn't cost much anywhere between
100 to 200 depending on what they're
offered but you need blood tests
every four months check your levels
and uh you'll feel a lot better i mean
in past two years i was feeling pretty
bad huh
you seemed like you were yeah you seemed
real grumpy
grumpy depressed um felt like
life was over like the hand of death was
[ __ ] chasing me that i didn't have
that
that i was gonna die soon anyway and a
lot of guys feel that way
especially if you live a [ __ ] very
intense life in your youth
guys that were always boring don't seem
to [ __ ] they don't seem to [ __ ]
feel it well it's just like anything
else it's just kind of like extremes if
you live to extremes once you don't have
those extremes anymore you're going to
feel the loss a lot more than somebody
that was just kind of more stable their
whole life right
i don't i mean yeah and that's a lot of
people wondered what the hell elvis had
and i'm gonna tell you what elvis had
elvis had [ __ ] low testosterone
he hit about 35 his career started to
falter and he went into a [ __ ] spiral
had you banged him up a little bit with
some hormone therapy he'd have been
right back on his feet
and he would have lived a lot longer and
he would have stayed away from those
painkillers
because he thought he was sick i know
the feeling i could now understand
you're not
sick it's just that you're kind of going
through a biological
shutting of down of your hormone system
your endocrine system
and [ __ ] there's somebody in there i
just helped i said look dude take clomid
and that'll kick that pituitary gland
awake you'll feel a lot better
if you take a little bit of clomid which
is a female fertility drug
he went to mexico and got some of that
and that [ __ ] is bouncing off
the goddamn walls
it's a good short-term solution man but
you're you're old enough to get on trt
bro
get on that you'll feel a lot better
you're gonna die anyway we only got 20
30 years left anyway max so
you can't abuse that [ __ ] when you're
young but when you're old
go ahead and bring yourself up to a
normal level [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
you got a lot of gas left in the tank
well like i said too
i guess i don't know [ __ ] doesn't [ __ ]
bothers me but [ __ ] doesn't bother me as
much
um because i don't know i always feel
like i have something to do i always
have like much
projects i got going i always feel like
i got [ __ ] i got to get done
so it's like even if i'm in a bad mood
i'm just kind of like man i got to do
this that and the other thing so i
always kind of feel like
a motivation to get [ __ ] done even
if i don't really feel like it they're
telling me to go back to blonde you
can't should go back to red well jd
you're probably going to go back to red
i've been thinking about it yeah i mean
even though i just bought a whole a
three pack of black dye but
you know i might i was thinking about it
again the other day because it did look
really interesting the same time you
don't have a short message
no i don't feel like i have short man
center i don't think i felt like a
normal guy i would really didn't care
about
well like i said i mean i you know i'm
only like five foot two five for three
yeah so to me it's like you never
read as short yeah um it never occurred
to me it really didn't
it didn't concur to me either i know
yeah it's like it really didn't i i'm
not one of those people that's just kind
of like oh they
i can understand like girls that are
real tall
like taller than average i can
understand them wanting to date a dude
that's taller than they are
i get that but i'm short so it was never
really an issue for me because
pretty much everybody's taller than me
um so
it was just not something that i ever
thought about taylor said oprah asked
prince did you
ever feel bad about your height and he
said uh no well only for basketball
yeah he can play yet all right um
they're just talking gram there's hammer
said elvis once said the key to
happiness is to have something to do
every day
someone to love and something to look
forward to evidently uh williams is
still alive
holy [ __ ] really yeah maniac says paul
williams
he said this i wrote rainbow connection
dropped them panties
right [ __ ] i mean that should be
sufficient yeah that's a great [ __ ]
drop down
and if that was the only thing he did
that would be sufficient but that's not
the only thing he did but
that was pretty rad because i love that
song
sophie talking about her brain chemicals
yeah yeah
sophie's a cool check we need to have
her back soon yeah you guys
you got to come visit again yeah she's
having she's got job interviews and all
kinds of stuff
well okay and uh she we did get that
first job that we contracted after we
got that back jenny or uh
jenny yeah she's helping me yeah yeah
she's helping me work on my next stuff
hernandez said my uncle got back from
vietnam he told it told me it took him a
couple years to get back to normal yeah
exactly and it probably took him longer
than that to get back to normal he just
didn't tell you
because that [ __ ] [ __ ] probably more
like five years well because after a
while you don't want to burden other
people with your [ __ ]
so it's just kind of like well i still
feel like crap but i'm not going to tell
anybody about it because
you know they have a right to have a
nice life so it's like why the hell
should i be whining all the time you
know what i'm saying
so if you're saying women ride hormone
waves their entire life
right a lot of times so we're just kind
of like used to it i guess
men aren't really using we're forming
these two and it's like oh here's this
[ __ ] again
every [ __ ] four weeks well men aren't
educated
about our home our hormone levels
if you want to know about that [ __ ] you
ask [ __ ] professional bodybuilders
they know
everything about that [ __ ] well and
they're abusing it the problem too
is that this is another thing where i
feel like a lot of dudes are
kind of grossed out by women talking
about their periods of their hormonal
cycles
and that's like damaging to men as well
because it's like look you guys have
hormones too
and you might be able to you know get
some insight into
your own [ __ ] by listening to women talk
about their [ __ ] because it's the same
problem you know what i'm saying um
that's why i always used to make like
period jokes and [ __ ] about tampons and
stuff because i know how much that
grosses dudes out and that makes me
laugh
stop propagandas it says tom what is
this clomid if you're feeling sick
i ca i'm not a doctor i cannot give
medical advice
uh not you know i can't prescribe [ __ ]
to people
clomid is a fertility drug that's what
it's sold
for for women to get them to ovulate
what it does is it stimulates the
pituitary gland in the brain
and then that cause that causes a
stimulation through the entire endocrine
system
of a woman and that includes ovulation
if you give it to a man it also
stimulates the endocrine system
including
sperm production testosterone production
then we're getting way off the [ __ ]
subject dude we're
talking about calm all right i mean i
was almost done yeah but we're almost
done okay
bodybuilders when they come off of
steroid cycles
their testosterone production is shut
down because they've been on
steroids steroid steroids is
a better version of testosterone it's
like the testosterone molecule but even
better
and when you start taking steroids
your own your body's natural
testosterone production shuts down
because your nuts are like why do i need
to make testosterone look what i got i
got all these
if you're not you could talk yeah there
you go why make
there's two of them with little nuts
with little faces on it that's what i
was imagining why the [ __ ] do i have to
work
why do i have to work yeah we just we're
gonna knock off work for the day yes we
are okay
i make this [ __ ] ass little
testosterone molecules that's nothing
compared to this [ __ ] that's in this
system
i don't you know i'm gonna shut down i'm
taking the day
off so after a while definitely after a
while some of those dudes
nuts get so small they damn near vanish
there's just a damn scrotum hanging
there
no no balls in them well
you become sadder than a ball yeah some
of those dudes have been on cycle for a
long long [ __ ] time
so they come off all those drugs and all
of a sudden there's no testosterone they
feel like
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then they start losing
everything that they gained
during that cycle and all that working
out they start losing muscle mass
because testosterone helps you maintain
muscle mass
it's it's it's an anabolic agent that
causes you to [ __ ] heal and to grow
that's what it does it's like very
similar to human growth hormone although
they work together
and a man's level is 10 times that as a
woman woman
heal using other hormones anyway
what they'll do is is you come off that
[ __ ]
steroid cycle and you got to get your
own natural production going so they
take clomid
they'll take that for a while and it'll
bang on the
two pituitary gland to get them to start
making them normal now are those normal
hormones levels enough
to maintain a [ __ ] who's 20
pounds 20 30 pounds over his genetic
potential
in muscle he'll know he's gonna lose all
that [ __ ] eventually
you know first of all do not equate
professional bodybuilding with anything
that i've said before about health and
longevity
those dudes are in a totally different
category those are like
biological drag racers they're not
healthy
and they tend not to live that long some
of them can't live long but they tend
not to
all depending on what they've done and
what era they came from
i'm not anti-steroids if you get injured
take steroids it'll help you heal
steroid abuse to get giant like that uh
especially at a young age that's gonna
affect your lifespan
now in your last 20 or 30 years of life
mild doses of things like anabolic
steroids
will that help you mild doses it could
jack in jack lalanne's case it did he
lived into his 90s
but he was not a gigantic bodybuilder he
was a regular
sized guy um you're just trying to
fool the body
into pretending that it's younger than
it is
and testosterone treatment hormone
treatments
and certain anabolic steroids can
extend life if used properly
but i'm not a doctor don't take my
advice
if you don't feel good go to a [ __ ]
go to a [ __ ] uh hormone replacement
clinic and get your blood test done and
and see what your blood results are see
if you're deficient in anything
and they can bring you up to a normal
level
a lot of bodybuilders that are at what's
called a super
physiological level in other words they
have the [ __ ] hormone
level of [ __ ] 420 year olds
that's that's how that's what their test
level is sometimes
don't do that not long term
kill you [ __ ] up your heart okay that's
all i gotta say
um i just had one more thing that i
wanted to get to because i said that i
talked about it earlier and i said i was
going to talk a little bit more about it
later
this is more about the shelly sykes case
uh that 19 year old who was taken out of
her car
so 1987 this dude
who was 30 his name was john marbert
king he calls up the police in el paso
texas and he says he confessed
that in 1986 he and his
friend 33 year old gerald petersworst
attacked shelley sykes while she was in
her car
and subsequently raped and strangled her
now as i said this was the case where
the car was found abandoned and there
was blood inside it and a
um footprint next to it the blood that
was found in shelly's car
uh was actually not shelley's blood it
was actually robert king's blood
he had cut his arm punching open her
window so he could drag her out of
the car and he had kind of sprayed blood
on the inside of the car
now uh gerald suarez told the cops that
he hid the body
in one of the fields nearby so where
some of the other bodies were found
so they asked both the dudes like to
find the body
um you know to kind of they kind of gave
them a deal they're like look we'll give
you a lesser sentence if you help us
find where the body is
um what ended up happening was that when
they were questioning them these two
[ __ ]
were basically like one of them blamed
the other one that guy was driving he
was the one that drugged her out of the
car
the other one said the same thing about
the other guys so they were just like
accusing each other no he didn't know he
did it it was that kind of thing
um you know they and they both said oh
we were really drunk and high that night
we don't
remember what we did um maybe shelley
was still alive
when after we when we buried her uh you
know maybe
i hit her with the shovel like while she
was in the [ __ ] grave it was like
[ __ ] like that
but i was too high i don't really
remember it was that kind of [ __ ]
now they actually uh the two of them
went on trial
as i said at the time they you know they
never found the body so
they put them on trial for aggravated
kidnapping which was kind of like the
worst
charge that they could do like without a
body uh they both got
life imprisonment in 1998
and uh since they had confessed to that
one they also kind of looked into him
for some of the other texas killing
fields uh
murders but uh they said pretty much
they hadn't done any other ones they
couldn't find any physical evidence
tying them to any other ones either
robert king actually died uh in jail in
october 2015 natural causes
i believe gerald zwarst is still alive
he's still in jail
uh he tried to go for pearl in 2017
but was denied so as far as i know he's
still in there although the other one is
dead
as i mentioned earlier there was a film
adaptation sort of
it came out in 2011. sam worthington is
in it uh jeffrey d morgan is in it
uh what's what's that little girl's name
chloe grace moritz yeah
little girl she's a woman but you know
she was little in this one
um she's in it too and it's called texas
killing fields it's on to be or it's on
pluto tv if you want to watch it for
free it's a good movie but
it's not it's a fictionalization
it's kind of like they took the idea of
the place
and sort of like made some sort of
similar cases
into a movie they didn't use any of the
real victims names
um they didn't do anything like that
they just kind of made a narrative out
of
you know and some people got saved which
didn't really happen
um so a lot of the [ __ ] in there so if
you're watching it don't watch it
thinking that's
anything to do with the actual case
because it's not it's a fictionalized
case but it's a good movie though
if you want to watch it i watched it
yesterday on to be
um and i guess that's pretty much all
about the texas killing field case so
if you want to talk about some other
[ __ ] we can do that now
because i got through all my notes well
let me answer
let me answer some questions that were
already asked okay there we go
hernandez wants to ask me what what
where did the [ __ ] bubblegum come
from
all right let me explain this to uh some
of the audience
and bodybuilding we got some dudes in
there and they're asking about [ __ ]
bodybuilding and [ __ ] exogenous
hormones and sugar [ __ ] like that they
want to know what
what's what there was something back in
the 90s that appeared it's very famous
today it's called [ __ ] they called it
bubble gut some of these
bodybuilders looked [ __ ] they were
huge as [ __ ] and they had these weird
round
[ __ ] guts that would pop out like
they were pregnant
the true name for that is palumbo-ism it
was named after a bodybuilder named
[ __ ] dave palumbo we talked about him
on them yeah
he's a funny guy and just talking about
palumbo-ism in front of dave palumbo
makes you [ __ ] pissed off as [ __ ]
nobody
knows what caused [ __ ] bubble gut
really
i suspect that it's alien impregnation
yeah
now um what it what those dudes in that
era were taking
a huge stack of different kind of drugs
to try to get as big as possible the 90s
and the early 2000s was an insane
time in [ __ ] bodybuilding where
aesthetics didn't matter
how it aesthetics means how what it
looks like it didn't matter to the
judges it was only
how [ __ ] big and how [ __ ] lean the
dude was they didn't care
it could even look like [ __ ] and that
guy would still win
all right so there's no telling what
caused that it was
something having to do with the drugs
they were taking
genetics may have been a factor because
they didn't all look that way
just some of them did but it's a good
thing that they
that they're getting away from that kind
of bodybuilding
the best bodybuilding of all times was
the golden era that was the 70s
during you know lou ferrigno arnold
schwarzenegger
those dudes would be considered small
today
but they had great aesthetics they
looked good all right and that's really
what
bodybuilding really should be it's about
looking good
there's also another category called
males fitness which is not quite that
big and they wear little [ __ ] shorts
don't make too much out of this [ __ ]
they're male beauty pageants that's all
they are it's not a sport
yeah it's all it is okay um now
i got zanda another guy said i would
never take any exogen
dude [ __ ] [ __ ] you're [ __ ] 20. of
course you're not going to take any
exogenous
hormones or steroids or anything and you
don't work out anyway [ __ ] xander i
[ __ ] seen your build
your [ __ ] your twig man you're a
little bit skinny guy
all right and [ __ ] [ __ ] you need and
you need to get in the
goddamn gym all right and [ __ ] and
lift
get a little get a little bit of size on
you because you look like you watch
television for a living all right
you're skinny you're too [ __ ] skinny
all right at least you're not fat
you're skinny though all right
you he goes i don't want to even live to
60. [ __ ] you don't know what you're
[ __ ] talking about because when you
get to 40 you still feel [ __ ] young
me and her were doing [ __ ] at 40 that
people at 20 couldn't do
and i mean i'm 48 and i still don't and
i still don't feel like an old person
i'm 51 she's 48
[ __ ] we would outperform most of you
[ __ ] at the club
well we can out drink out drinks
[Laughter]
out charm [ __ ] everybody [ __ ]
knows us when we go to the [ __ ] club
what's up it's not the idea is
you should you should be good looking
for as long as you can
until you die i'm trying to look good at
70.
now a lot of these people you look at
sly sly's bodies
we're talking about sylvester stallone's
body looks [ __ ] great
he's pushing 70. okay his face is [ __ ]
up
but you have to understand that he was
an experiment from another era
he was taking antibiotics yeah all this
shit's experimenting will make him
bigger
stronger yes faster right they didn't
quite know what they were doing back
then
he's a great guy very talented i like
salah sly he's real intelligent
[ __ ] he's a very good actor he's very
talented he knows what what a good story
is he could write all right he's got a
lot of friends i would
i really respect the dude
back about rambo three around that time
he started training with the golden era
guys
all right [ __ ] lou ferrigno [ __ ]
uh
a [ __ ] um it was um who arnold's
friend
the dude from conan one what was his
name a little italian guy
oh i know you talk about i can't think
name what his name is
he was um he was
sylvester stallone's workout partner and
trainer
sylvester stallone probably got on uh of
one of the earlier versions of anabolic
steroids which would
anavar which is pretty gentle by today's
standards
but he took that for a long time okay
you can't it's not really good to take
large amounts of anabolic steroids
from an early age you're only going to
be able to run that for so long
by the time you're 50 or 60 you're gonna
start developing certain problems
so what what slide did is he got off a
lot of those anabolics he went to hgh
which would be human growth hormone you
can work out and you can get big on
human growth hormone
but it distorts your face so what he did
was he [ __ ]
had a little nips and tucks here to
change his face to try to put his face
back
okay he's looking a lot better than he
did
he's in good health very good health if
you if it's done right
even though he abused it if it's done
right you can live a long time even
though he kind of abused you
a good female equivalence would be
there's a porn star named ryan connor
she was taking hgh
she's my age she looks [ __ ] fantastic
she had to get a nose job because her
nose got pretty [ __ ] big i was
showing it to
to sophie because sophie's into fitness
too i showed it to sophie i said
look at her nose changed because yeah
that's that hgh
but she got nice big legs nice big booty
uh her daughter is a porn star too
that's some weird [ __ ] when you think
about it it is kind of weird that's a
weird [ __ ] yeah
walking in mom's footsteps and [ __ ] but
um
look at ryan connors think she's 50 51
years old she claims i think 51 she
might be a little bit older because i've
remembered her my whole life she was in
porn when i was a teenager so
she's got to be older than that but she
does great
these things can be used
but they have to be used in reasonable
amounts and you want to do this [ __ ] in
middle age
towards the end because if they're
abused early on in the early part of
your life
there's not going to be any [ __ ] gas
left in your tank by the time you're 50
or 60 you're not gonna be able to do
anything
well it's just kind of like smoking like
smoking i feel like if you start smoking
when you're a teenager and you smoke
back for decades then yeah you'll get
lung cancer you're gonna get lung cancer
if you don't if you don't smoke in this
and then you kind of start later
like then it's probably okay if you
started smoking it's still not good but
if you started smoking at 60 it's not
going to make a bigger
smoke up no smoke up it's not going to
make a bit of [ __ ] difference because
it takes a long time it's bad for you
but it takes a long time right
uh so when done correctly some people go
oh those antibodies oh i would never do
anything about
yeah you would yes you [ __ ] would do
it if you're 50 years old
followed as [ __ ] and you're gonna
[ __ ] look like an old [ __ ] person
like [ __ ] with you yeah you're going
to remember your perspective
here you go [ __ ] take this now go
work out you'll feel a lot better you'll
look a lot better you go
god damn boom i came out of that goddamn
machine captain america came out of
what do you have to lose you only got 20
years of life left
well like i said it was like a sexy
[ __ ] as long as you didn't [ __ ]
your [ __ ] up and yeah when you were
young you can get away with a lot you
can get away with a lot
yeah sophie said she can't believe
she'll be 30 this year feels like i
wasted the most fun
years you did no you did [ __ ] you know
that's so bad
some people can turn things around later
well no it's like i don't i feel like i
didn't
really get my [ __ ] together until i was
about 40. i was about 38
30 yeah 38. yeah you really don't
understand what you're
dealing with until you come up i really
got my that's when i got my [ __ ]
together i was like this is who i am
this is kind of like so don't feel like
so if you're like late 20s or 30s like
don't feel like oh i'm so old and i
wasted everything it's really not
yeah you're just not hormonally set up
to be a reasonable person
when you're in your [ __ ] teens
twenties
thirties you just nobody is yes
[Laughter]
nobody wants teens or 20 year old
anybody running anything
okay let's see if there's any questions
about the [ __ ]
you know because there's any more
questions [ __ ] man talking about the
case
because i you know it's like i remember
although i will say i i'm a bad example
i guess because i
i didn't go too [ __ ] crazy in my
teens or 20s or anything like that i
didn't do a bunch of stupid [ __ ] or
anything
um but most people do do stupid [ __ ]
tina says diet exercise and [ __ ]
natural remedies
uh partly correct diet exercise natural
remedies
no no won't that'll only take you so
far yeah amanda smith said the same
thing i agree my mid-30s is when i
actually got my stuff together
so yeah anybody that's just in their 20s
or something don't worry about it
um everybody's [ __ ] up everybody's
confused at that age
when you get into your mid to late 30s
you'll start to like
sort it out i didn't source it until it
was 38 at least
yeah you know people talking about i'm
56 you feel young you're always
you always feel young if your health is
good if your health is good go ahead and
[ __ ] around when you're in your future
well a lot of it's like mental attitude
too yeah
it's like because i kind of feel like
part of the reason why i don't feel like
an old person
is because i mentally don't feel like an
old person you know what i mean i don't
have an attitude of an old person
because it's weird sometimes i see
people like walking around i'm like man
look at that old fart over there
whatever and then i feel like
they're probably the same age as me but
i still i still think of them as an old
person because they seem like an old
person to me just because of their body
language or because of
[ __ ] they're talking about or something
like that so
i don't know it's like a really weird
i don't know if everybody goes through
the same [ __ ] i don't know
maybe it's it maybe it's a generational
thing because
we were kind of like the first
generation
you know after the boomers generation x
and we were kind of the first ones we
were all into the punk rock and we were
all into that kind of [ __ ]
and we were the first ones that were
just kind of like man [ __ ] this we do we
don't want all this
we don't want all this [ __ ] right you
know and um
you know we we don't want to be old
people we don't want to be like that
and so you know i i definitely feel like
it has
i don't know it'll be it'll be
interesting to see how people our age
once we're in our 70 70s and 80s like
once we're all in the old folks home
with all our tattoos and wearing [ __ ]
we'll be we'll be 80 and like wearing
[ __ ] social distortion shirts and
[ __ ]
yeah that's like that always kind of
like made me laugh like think of that
stop propaganda says tom i wish life was
so easy to control
i broke my neck in a car accident back
in 2001.
because of this bone graft is taken from
my
back bone to repair the neck my my hip
is shot
i can barely walk yeah you know [ __ ]
damage
physical damage from accidents i mean
you know that's that's a totally
different game i'm not really
talking about that i'm talking about
people who are
people who are normal or otherwise
healthy just aging
um it's it's much easier
to try to protect the health you have
than to lose your health and try to
regain it
that's a that's a different challenge
that's something you're going to have to
research on your own
looking maybe something about stem cell
stem cell infusions and [ __ ]
or you know i don't know i i i'd have to
see you i'm not a doctor
you go get a friend ryan schwartz says
don't have kids it keeps you young yeah
i'm
yeah not not to [ __ ] on people to have
kids but i kind of think there might be
something to that
um because we were kind of talking about
this yesterday i was just kind of like i
think i decided when i was a teenager
yeah and i'm not real that's not really
something i want to do and uh
my mom even told cause my mom loves kids
she had four of them i have three
siblings and she was just like oh you'll
change your mind when you get older
never happened i just got caught up in
it never happened yeah i never had the
chance because i was always caught up in
something else that i was doing for some
kind of [ __ ] stupid-ass government
agency or something it's like i thought
about it a couple times and then i
thought about it for like you know a few
minutes and i'd be like
nah not for me i'm just i don't know i'm
just not
i don't know i'm just not like what did
you know maybe that's because
like when we got pookie and it's like
she's our kid but in a lot of ways she's
a lot better than a human child
we don't have to talk to it well we
don't we don't have to pay for her to go
to college
you gotta understand something that she
tried to she doesn't she doesn't come to
be a teenager and she's like i'm gonna
go and get high with my friends and it's
like you know like i said you don't have
to pay for her to go to college
she just like stays cute and adorable
her whole entire life
i can talk to her she doesn't like sass
me back
yeah you can kind of leave her on her to
her own devices as long as you kind of
watch out for because sometimes she
might like do some crazy [ __ ]
she's good though she doesn't tear up
[ __ ] in the house too much
you know what i mean she's so she's
better than him again but
you know like i said i i do think that
having kids
for some people um does kind of like
suck out your life force
just saying okay so um
justin says you ain't out drinking me
tom my challenge
[Laughter]
no i don't know man [ __ ] it's hard to
tell how much we've been drinking
well this is my second one and you said
you made him a little bit weaker and i
don't feel i feel
buzzed but not that drunk it's still
early too and we got a movies and [ __ ]
to watch yeah
i think there's only quarterbacks eight
yeah do you guys uh have any any
questions about the case or any other
kind of questions you can go ahead and
drop them
in the comment section michael schaefer
says no offense jenny wouldn't be a good
parent
i probably wouldn't i said tom would
probably be a good dad
you probably you probably would you
probably would i don't think i
think i'd be a horrible parent i think i
would be
like it it sucks because i feel like i
wouldn't want to be but i feel like i'd
be super super overprotective
and then i would resent myself for being
overprotective you know what i'm saying
i kind of feel like that's what would
probably happen i don't know what would
happen
sophie says i don't mind kids but i hate
babies
[Laughter]
terry said thanks for a great show guys
yeah kids kind of suck
but you know all right well if there's
no more questions we should go ahead and
just shut it down
see we didn't do too bad three hours and
24 minutes and
a long show the stream didn't drop the
whole entire time
i made sure not to talk at all
he made sure not to talk at all yeah
yeah you didn't you didn't you went off
on a couple tangents but nothing too
egregious yeah so i was still able to
like keep to my
t-shirt if we would adopt no tea we
wouldn't it's too late in life
i'm too old too old for that [ __ ] i'm
too tired yeah
you know in my just having kitties is
enough i was married before but i broke
up with my wife
uh about a year and a half into it okay
and i got married uh [ __ ] at around
29 or so that's really the time for a
man
to [ __ ] have kids
late 20s early 30s i mean we can do it
forever
it's just that your patience and your
energy level
and your priorities change as you get
older you're kind of designed
to have kids in your 20s that's the best
time to have well when you have the
energy you have a lot of energy and
you're young
and then you can grow up with the kids
all right
now it's time to have a kid i'd be dead
by the time the kid was a [ __ ]
teenager
and then that's like [ __ ] over the
kid because now they're like [ __ ]
[ __ ] not around to help me
i'm locked up [ __ ] bail me out god
damn it
so and then and [ __ ]
[ __ ] man [ __ ] i put my parents to the
[ __ ] ringer as i was growing up
so there's i didn't think i was
constantly worried that i'd get killed
going doing this and that and [ __ ]
going over here so
i'm too old for that [ __ ] because i know
my genome
if i were to spawn out a creation
that [ __ ] would be [ __ ] wild it would
be [ __ ] wild it would put me through
the ringer yeah i don't know if i'd
if it was a girl it'd be even worse i'd
be giving birth some kind of [ __ ]
porn star [ __ ] goddess
porn star goddess [ __ ] i'm like
no you have to understand something you
can't sell [ __ ] that's not that's
against the rules you can't sell [ __ ]
if that's what you choose to do she's up
up at harvard and yale set up and [ __ ]
yeah it'd be like that
but i because that's the thing it's like
in principle it's a good idea
but when it's your daughter yeah you
don't want them down yeah it'd be a
total psychopath
that's a i always this was what i always
um oh i wanted to scott asked me if we
had reviewed black mountainside we
haven't
i actually started watching it and then
i never finished it but it's like i
really want to finish watching it
because it seemed like really really
good i just didn't get around to like
finishing it but so we
we will like review it one of these days
i promise but we haven't reviewed it so
far
my biggest fear was that i would have a
kid
and it would turn out the complete
opposite to me
yeah and that would be on the
intellectual be dumb as [ __ ]
yeah it would just be like some dumb
like super
religious like [ __ ] weirdo and i
would just be like
whose [ __ ] child can't be like the
christina applegate character from
married with children and be like that
that's a total opposite kind of or
actually i don't know i like i kind of
imagined somebody that was like kind of
[ __ ]
i don't know like sophie's saying it's a
great show says the right amount of
sidetracks and drinks and everything got
and it was three and a half hours the
timing's perfect okay
this is how the show should be if you
ask me
in terms of time kind of it's here
that's another shirt dude if i spawn a
creation
it will be it'd be a sex goddess that's
what would happen if it was
dude con
we we understand the genome okay [ __ ]
i've seen the female and my female
ancestors all right
on my side of the family
they're [ __ ] dangerous man they did
this what they are [ __ ] psychopathic
sex goddesses that's what they [ __ ]
were
when you sell them when they're young
bombshells
they're like i'm gonna get into it
i got pictures to prove the [ __ ] that
i'm saying
they look good everyone's like yeah my
aunts and my mom
when they were young they all looked
good they were all [ __ ] crazy
all of them were [ __ ] crazy she can
attest they're [ __ ] crazy
oh yeah yeah they're [ __ ] great and
i'm not one of those federal [ __ ] be
crazy but like women are crazy that's
just something that dudes tell
the like show women up but some women
are indeed crazy and
yeah yeah on my side of the family
they're all [ __ ] crazy
and that's what the in in a modern
society that's what they would end up
being
which i kind of feel like maybe that's
why
i don't know like i i feel like maybe
that's why you were kind of surprised
that i was normal
because you were so used to i was used
to crazy crazy chicks
yeah because that's kind of like what
you were
that's what you were around all the time
yeah [ __ ] crazy
what was california too i mean
i don't think i'm crazy although i feel
like crazy people that's the first thing
they say is that they're not crazy yeah
i don't think i'm crazy though okay not
not largely
well i don't know in some ways maybe um
lucy says i'm a newbie hey welcome have
you reviewed the classic trick or treat
yes we got um the the anthology one was
sam yes we have
uh that's one of our movie
retrospectives i can't believe how what
i can't remember how long ago we did
that maybe i feel like we did it not
this past halloween but maybe the one
before that 2018
yeah i don't know so it was not it was
it was a while back um
if you're talking about the one from the
80s about the hair metal band
that was called trick or treat no
but i have seen it and it was terrible
but fun
it was yeah we haven't done that one but
we've done
we've done the anthology one tom did you
ever have yellow fever in japan no i
never went to japan other than like a
couple of days i was stationed in korea
yeah okay
i know what he's talking about yeah well
everybody that kind of a yellow female
yeah
the other kind no it's just that you get
stationed a place like korea man
man man does what he does
ladies are ladies yeah that's that's the
deal
yeah i mean and uh the dick doesn't
discriminate
well you know it does it does
it discriminates it's just that it's
it's not you know
ethnic group and race may not be a
factor it's more about
the individual woman it's more about the
appeal of it
that's very cool well of course well you
know it's all
a case-by-case basis well that's kind of
how we should approach everything
right now at all times being in the
service when you go to korea
the professional trade is also a fact
it's a factor
because you know you when they release
you from
you know when i was at camp greaves we
were on the dmz
so i only got 24 hour one 24 hour pass a
month we were kind of like a maximum
security prison
so when you go back you when you go back
to like soul
or [ __ ] tongue desean you're not
gonna have a girlfriend as you know it
dude you're gonna go to the [ __ ] club
these are hooker clubs yeah and you had
a whole army of young american men
going to help the south koreans and then
you got a whole
army of south korean girls going to help
the [ __ ] american men get the job
done
this is a [ __ ] a south korean
government
effort to entertain
young american men overseas and to get
as much of their money as possible
out of the [ __ ] american pocket into
the south korean economy
because that's american taxpayer funds
paying you they want some of that money
they know those girls are going to spend
that money back in their economy they
know exactly what they're doing
they teach them english they try back in
that era they
taught them english they trained them up
in american culture
and turned them into dancers they got
them dressed up in the damn cowgirl
outfits with the [ __ ] six shooters
and the cowboy hats and the french
and they got some of them dressed up
like little [ __ ] rap star girls
[ __ ] on it
and
they know the deal and you know the deal
and there's not a big difference between
you two
between the two of you you're all the
same age everybody looks good it's good
looking
fit american guys in their 20s and good
looking korean girls in their 20s some
of them older in their 40s but you
couldn't tell until it was too late
it didn't matter until it was too late
god damn it
i was like you're an old baby
45 and i'm like yeah
whatever you know korean women they age
well they age very well
and but no they had all kinds of [ __ ]
it was fun it was fun and it wasn't
serious and it did not have that
seedy quality to it like you would think
that it would
well because it's a lot more acceptable
yeah it's part of their culture and it
was also part of the economy and it was
part of the
in those days it was part of the army
system the army the american medics went
in and
everybody had licenses it was like
something out of europe
it was all see i think that's a much
better situation because no one's
necessarily being exploited like
everyone kind of knows what the deal is
yeah everyone is being tested everyone's
safe
it's like it's a you know it's a
controlled environment and it wasn't
really a mind [ __ ] there's not
really any emotion involved in it it's
not really the same as like
having sex with a regular woman it's not
it's like screwing the waitress
you know what i mean it's not really
that personal
yeah it's like sport you know but it's
like
it's like a sport yeah it's like chinese
disneyland welcome
to sports yeah in the club in the club
behind the club there's a bunch of
apartments that they all live in it's
all connected
and you go into their rooms man and i
swear to god they got the colored lights
and it looks like chinese disneyland
they got all these [ __ ] dragons and
[ __ ] chinese looking
it's korean but in your mind it looks
like chinese the
you know like chinese looking furniture
and [ __ ] gigantic [ __ ] beds and
music and [ __ ] you're like yeah all
right you know it's just entertainment
well yeah it's all geared toward your
entertainment like yeah it's all
entertainment well they're trying to
keep you away from
from korean civilians sure they don't
want you
[ __ ] up normal calm lifestyle of a
[ __ ]
of korean civilian families they don't
want you in there
because you will [ __ ] [ __ ] up of course
you'll [ __ ] it up
yeah they have a very small the korean
society had a very kind of like
small overton window of acceptability
and there was nothing acceptable about
american gi's
no nothing like you guys are gonna wreck
all the [ __ ]
wreck all this [ __ ] just just showing up
adds
too much stink
[Laughter]
just too much goddamn stink
try to go into the [ __ ] restaurant
and they go oh no
like what no no no no no they just say
no
what are you never letting me when she
never let me in the restaurant no no no
no no
out no no no yeah no white
oh no white okay what they think that
you were gonna poop in your hands and
throw it at the wall or something
no it's because they're just [ __ ]
korean people in there they don't want
to see no [ __ ] white people coming in
there
they lose their appetite or something
you know
scaring them scaring them too much
they're very shy people
yeah it's like you're making us you lose
our happiness and then you go
what's funny is that you go to the
[ __ ] club with your boy right and he
might be black you try to go in there
and they separate you from him they say
you
go to that club oh
that's how we're playing that's how
we're playing this club's for whites
only then that one's for the blacks
ain't that some [ __ ] that is some [ __ ]
yeah not good [ __ ]
but that's just how they're gonna
[ __ ] play everybody had to be
separated
yeah everybody has fun in there
yeah yeah he can't come in you can come
in but he can't come in
yeah okay and what are you gonna do
protest this is their country
yeah i mean and they will lock your ass
up yeah yeah
so thank you stop prop when is the next
loot drop i know we really need to do
that
uh we need to do some shirts we need to
design some new shirts
maybe we can do that this week and we'll
cover tina says are they shy are they
racist
they're racist i'm just being i'm just
being
um polite
[Laughter]
korea china and japan
are a [ __ ] very homogenous societies
koreans the japanese and the chinese
hate each other
they're racist against each other um
they do not like well okay i gotta put
this way
they don't like black people at all
they'll tolerate white people
um they do not differentiate between
latinos and white to them that's just
more white people
um
they're [ __ ] a highly controlled now
what i'm telling you this is from the
90s i don't know how much has changed
korea in 1990 91 around that time
was kind of like going back to 1935
that's what it was like and what was
funny is that some of the korean women
didn't play any of this [ __ ]
and they liked they might like western
guys more than their own and they would
[ __ ] complain about korean guys
that they were backwards so it was just
a weird
time i don't know if it's still like
that but probably is
probably i mean that was a long time ago
but i don't know i haven't been there so
i don't it's probably still kind of like
that yeah um
it's it's not our country so you can't
tell them how to think if they don't
like you they don't like you
what are you gonna do beat their ass
because they don't like you that's gonna
make them like you no
there's nothing you can do that's
usually not the best way to get people
to like you just a pro tip
you don't like me i'm going to kick your
ass until you do like me yeah
yeah see what's going on about lighter
blood and skin bleaching
yeah but you know that's only like the
certain that's only
up to a certain point
in korea koreans were the superior race
they just
are that's how they were in their minds
koreans were better than any kind of
mixed relationship they weren't into
that
out of the foreigners they kind of had
kind of this [ __ ] weird
kind of fetishism of white people
um they did fetishize white people but
they
still thought they were better than you
it was just like a fetishization of
white people
um but no yeah no black people were like
uh
i wouldn't say that they didn't think
black people were bad
they just thought black people were
lower than everybody else which that's
something that you kind of have to like
what the [ __ ]
that's like going back to like i said
that's like that's some racist [ __ ] man
uh yeah a little bit this okay
the western society is a society that is
not a top-down society it's a network
of people that roughly consider
themselves to be the same
they might be a little bit higher or
lower depending on their income or their
abilities or their charisma
but that's mostly has to do with their
personality and who they are personally
you know what i mean not so much by
their race
all right the entire east
is a is a hierarchy it's about who is
above who
and who is below who and they have
it's just something about the way their
entire
civilizations are [ __ ] organized it
has to do with
the god emperor being on top and he's
chinese or korean or japan
going back to imperial japan and then
hit the royal families and then
the high business families and oligarchs
and then this and
so everything is a top-down
hierarchy which is that's
actually kind of like the norm that's
the
norm of the world most of the world's
like that
and but so is the animal kingdom prey
and predator and who is above who
america and the west with this [ __ ]
moral amorphous
network of people side by side
trying to work [ __ ] out and do things
together like a rock group
that's very western and very american
that's not normal for the rest of the
world
in some countries that's coming but it's
just that's not their heritage
and that's just the reality you know
um it's
i kind of understand it do i agree with
it no
but i understand why it's like that it's
just part of their evolution
yeah you know stomp prop told me to read
the rest of the message because
uh he gave us a super chat then he says
when is the next loot drop guys at which
point i was just kind of like oh we
should make some more t-shirts but he
says
make it a book jenny next time so there
you go maybe we should send some books
out we haven't done that in a little
while
i don't know i'll think about that i'm
i'm still working on new ones
so we'll see how it goes i was if i if i
got the [ __ ]
cookbook done which i've been working on
i worked on it all day yesterday
actually and a little bit today
we could send those out if you guys wait
a little bit longer because it is kind
of almost done but you know we'll see
we'll see how it goes um
you know uh where was i
koreans like americans who have light
hair
and because in their minds that's what
americans should be
has anybody ever noticed that jenny has
more ink than tom
i do actually yeah i've got this i got
this
and i got this and this one is actually
a cover-up of another one because i used
to have like a smaller one here
and then this sleeve was like a cover-up
i want more but i actually
you know what i wanted i wanted a big
back piece based on
edgar allan poe's mask of the red death
but i just haven't been able to afford
it
but i had it kind of planned out and
sort of sketched and uh
i don't know maybe maybe someday i'll
get it
[Laughter]
where is pookie tonight she was in here
just a second ago
she was running around and kind of
looking at me like
no uh t this she's asking to show up to
this says the united states is a cast
society too
uh well no not really well it is but to
a lesser extent a lot lesser
a lot less to a lesser you can rise or
fall uh
to your level depending on in your your
[ __ ]
your race doesn't have much to do with
it all you gotta do is just go to the
damn
some of these [ __ ] places like out in
uh appalachia
and you'll see white people poorer than
just [ __ ] any [ __ ]
anybody poured in bread they're just
terrible
terrible living conditions in certain
areas
and then you'll see black people who are
rich and famous that have a lot of power
and [ __ ] somewhere on the supreme
court there's a lot of mobility a lot
more
okay it's not great but it's better than
some places
and it's better than it is a lot better
than [ __ ] most places i can't
think of any any other place where
it's bet i can't think of a better place
where there's mobil
more mobility and really what it has to
do with is that here you're it's a lot
more likely that you're treated as an
individual
now the difference is is that you're
treated as an
individual based upon your economic
power how much money you have
but that's kind of the way it is
everywhere
uh-oh uh-oh money solves all problems
there's pookie
[Laughter]
money solvers and and
and that's not only like between races
that's within races a rich white person
is
far more powerful than a rich white than
a poor white person
far more it's really
the the greatest the greatest uh [ __ ]
what do you call it
what's your one tweet she's trying to go
back outside
the greatest factor that makes any
difference in any people's lives is
[ __ ] money
well yeah it doesn't have anything to do
with race and money i mean if you're
rich it doesn't
really matter you can get away with that
pretty much anything
yeah i guess it's still fairly early i
think it's 8 36.
uh dan says hey guys been here all the
while just not well oh man
i hope you're feeling better there dan
i mean uh
hopefully pokey i heard her name yeah
she's she's like
okay she's she wants to go on the back
porch there's another kitty out there
that she made
friends yeah in a true cast system the
money doesn't matter it's just
everything about family
santa says i'm a poor white white person
yeah me too
[Laughter]
i am also a poor white person but you
know i've always been a poor white
person it sucks but you know you get
used to it after a while
yeah pookie uh made a little friend i
don't know whose cat this is it belongs
to someone i'm sure it's not
it's not a stray cat who is gray like
her
and almost the same size as her a little
bit bigger but kind of fluffier
obviously as a tail
and they're like they're like
fascinated with each other i guess she
came by i don't know if the other cat's
a female or not
but i guess she came by last night on
the porch and pookie was out there
sitting at the porch like they were
looking to each other
and every now and then this other cat
comes by like at two or three in the
morning and i hear her out there going
in and then like pookie's like at the
window looking out going there she's
here she's here
she's talking about black people she
knew that worked and cut in in korea and
they asked about africa
you hear something else about funny
about about [ __ ] the army
in army in the army pretty much
everybody got along
but you could tell who hung out with who
okay about kind of here's the weird
thing
when you weren't in when you weren't on
duty
african-american guys and white guys
wouldn't always hang out with each other
okay but what was funny is that
guys that were from africa haiti or
jamaica that were in the army
pretty much only hung out with each
other or with white guys they didn't
like african americans
yeah they just didn't and it has
something to do with culture
they well yeah they wouldn't gravitate
towards they wouldn't gravitate they
wouldn't gravitate towards
african-americans
they'd hang out with [ __ ] like
anglo-americans
like in jamaicans and
haitians and africans you know there's
just something about
you would think there'd be a lot more of
a difference
but no it was kind of like dealing with
jamaica is like dealing with british
it's almost kind of like a british
person it's just
culture had more to do with things than
than color did
yeah in that situation upbringing in the
culture yeah scott asked is pookie fixed
yes we got her fixed
uh when she was still pretty young she
was probably only six or seven months
old
we got her fixed so she's never had
i think she went into heat one time like
a week before her appointment
and that was the only time that happened
i had video of it because it was very
sad and very fun
she was inside well we wouldn't we
wouldn't not let her out if she
she we wouldn't let her run around in
the backyard if she was not fixed
because uh yeah we don't do that kind of
[ __ ] both the kitties are fixed
um so all right so we almost got to four
hours that's pretty good huh
yeah i mean [ __ ] the show's long as
[ __ ] but we ended the show what an hour
ago
everybody else is just hanging out yeah
that's cool i mean
i got through all the [ __ ] i'm not super
drunk yeah we need an
all pooky show we all need a pookie show
a pookie show
yeah an all pooky show wrong with that
[ __ ] i don't think
yeah like two seconds
[Laughter]
yeah you can't keep her bye i'm gonna go
play and then i'm gonna go sleep in my
cat tree
yeah yeah
yeah she would she would not hang out
for that [ __ ] it's like she'll come up
and be like what are you doing why are
you not paying attention to me but you
know what i mean
sometimes when we're watching tv or like
watching a movie she'll
and she's mad that we're not paying
attention she'll jump up in front of the
movie and then she'll just kind of like
stand there so all you can see is her
little silhouette
you know i call it mystery pookie
theater 3000 because you could see her
little silhouette in front of the
[ __ ] movie all the time
all right so you're ready to wrap it up
you look like you're about wrapped
you're ready to wrap
earlier let's watch a movie okay yeah
it's not even nine o'clock
watch that [ __ ] elvis [ __ ] thing
that i was telling you about you'll like
that
which one the one that was called elvis
in the black community and then there's
there's people reacting to it oh i
thought it was the one with kurt russell
in it no it's it's
it's a documentary that somebody put
together on youtube out of all this [ __ ]
over the years
that was recorded they got down [ __ ]
dixie crap [ __ ] clan [ __ ]
calling elvis to n word and breaking his
[ __ ] records and all kinds of [ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ] that was that they tried
to [ __ ] disappear
over the years of [ __ ] about elvis
because back in the day there was no
youtube
if something played on television it
played once and then it was gone
you couldn't record it but now they
brought up all these recordings and try
to put a timeline of how that [ __ ]
happened and the [ __ ] that he said and
[ __ ] that he didn't say
and then [ __ ] bb king said [ __ ] the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] the [ __ ] um um oh [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] drunk it's just [ __ ] that
people
said about him during the time what
james brown said about him
you know just you'll see you'll see lucy
said tell pookie my six cats perk up
when they see her
yeah oh that's so cute it's like hey
it's another kitty
yeah pookie gets like that when she sees
another kitty on the tv too she's like
well
she says she's gonna watch out five
minutes yeah kitty yeah watch elvis in
the black community some kind of
reaction you know
they'll have they got dudes reacting
they got [ __ ] they got girls reacting
you'll see you'll see what i'm talking
about
usually it's one part part one and part
two because it's kind of long
maybe about a half hour and then some of
the songs man
[ __ ] you know like in the ghetto and
[ __ ] he had all kinds of really cool
[ __ ] songs elvis was he was the
[ __ ] mississippi messiah
and orion when he wants to [ __ ] rose
up from the crypt
and he came back when he came back to
save us all
sure all right
all right go ahead we gotta wrap this up
man i gotta i gotta pee we gotta watch a
movie it's like come on
yeah um yeah so we'll be back tomorrow
at 3 p.m eastern standard time
doing a matinee probably talk about uh
season one of true detective which
sophie sent us on blu-ray
guys haven't seen true detective season
one go ahead and watch this we haven't
seen the other two seasons but they're
not related so it's like it but yeah it
was awesome so we want to talk about
that tomorrow
um also shutter just added the dark and
the wicked which a couple of people have
requested that we review so we'll
probably do that one on monday but yeah
we'll be back
tomorrow for another live stream talking
to a movie i'm so so happy that this
[ __ ] didn't crash this time
oh my god i can't even tell you uh so
remember like share subscribe and all
your social media
go to our patreon go there's a you know
link at the sidebar on our
blog to go to a paypal if you want to
like give a one-time donation
anything that you guys can give your
support for the show is always much
appreciated
we will see you guys tomorrow thank you
for dropping by bye